you
okay folks i think we're ready to go
ahead here
we have several of our bills which are
currently being heard down in senate
education at this moment
right now they're hearing the bill
dealing with um
the require request that we get the
statutory books here and annotated
versions at the beginning of the session
rather than at the end
that's uh that was started at nine
o'clock and at 9 15 senator khan is
introducing the bill that we submitted
on my behalf the granite state merger
with the unh system which of course came
out here unanimously was approved by
higher ed unanimously and and by all the
community college and university system
as well so there shouldn't be much of a
problem there but these are occurring at
the same time and linda's back now so we
can go ahead
i hope it went well
i know that some of the other
departments around here are not too keen
about us asking for these uh hard copies
in the annotated version
yeah
oh yeah ols is not very happy about it
not very happy i i was hammered just
after we passed that bill here
well they think the next thing we're
going to ask for is sticky notes that we
can put in the annotated version so it's
they say it's never going to end
alrighty so what we have today is we
have uh on
we have to close out all these bills one
thing i would request that yesterday we
i was supposed to receive about 17
reports be it a minority majority or
committee reports um i haven't got them
all in yet i've gotten over half of them
and which is an accomplishment for this
group
um
but
we need to have them all in by to close
the shop tonight
because that gives lindsay just tomorrow
morning to get the stuff done
and get things encounters so please you
know when you make a motion today
understand that with that motion comes
your task of writing a blurb or a
committee report
so
so you know
i hope we get some volunteers to make
motions
okay
so with that
so after that
um we have some substitutes here this
morning and
mr clerk can you do you have a list of
those that are subbing today
okay we have representative notter here
for um
melissa litchfield to my left we have uh
don johnson for uh ralph baum
sitting over in ralph's chair there
um we have for michael
moffatt
represented bernstein
and for mary beth
jack
welcome he was the first one here today
he came in around 8 o'clock
so
pardon me
i don't know but i was running around
doing things
so yeah we've been having a few subs so
that's where we are with the daca today
and i appreciate everybody taking the
time to volunteer to come in and sub
so we have a
laundry list here of bills which we got
to address
and i'm going to try to work us into
some of this easy getting into it i'd
like to start out with 1164.
it's an easy one hopefully
i should knock on wood
turn to it
okay 1164
is reviving the agriculture in the
classroom committee
a committee that i didn't even know
existed before this bill came in
so
we have had um
discussion with the commissioner
and with the
sponsor of the bill
had the hearing and
uh is there a motion on on the floor
or is there a person wanting to put
forward a motion i shouldn't have
discussed all that representative
cordelli
okay
okay we have a motion to ought to pass
is there a second representative hobson
representative cordelli do you have any
discussion
no but i think maybe there's an
amendment um yes there is
is that a amendment
um
0939h
i don't have a hot clue
what it is it's an amendment
that changes uh as the bill was
introduced on page one
on line 28 a member of that
committee is the representative of the
new hampshire plant growers association
we are told by the commission of the
plant growers association doesn't exist
anymore but there is a new association a
fruit growers
association which would replace that and
i believe that's exactly what the
amendment does
yeah we handed a bunch of uh there may
be it's uh amendment and i'd like to put
forth that uh make a motion to
uh amend uh 1164 with amendment 0939h
is there a second
second
okay represent quarterly seconds of
motion so i can
does everybody have a copy of it you're
welcome look at mine represent woodcock
if you need it
it simply says take out the one and a
represent of the fruit growers
association appointed by the governor
that's the amendment
mr chairman i have that emotion
that was the that was the
that was to ought to pass we have
the amendment
and i introdu that was introduced and
then we had this amendment as and put
forward for discussion right now
represent cornell is is fruit growers
replacing plant growers is that what
you're doing okay black or plant growers
doesn't exist anymore so it's replacing
so it just goes right into the same line
any further discussion
on the amendment
okay uh
representative nelson
you can you can do it you can do a show
of hands on them
okay um
we have a motion to floor
ought to pass as amended so the motion
will be
to approve
1164 as amended this is a bill dealing
with revising revising the agriculture
in the classroom committee further
discussion
mr chair yes um thank you very much um
the um
really i think the the concern that um
that we have on this that was aired
specifically by representative walls
uh several weeks ago
revolves around the um the
the base bill
you know as amended
on pay on page
one
lines um
eight through ten
and where where there's a non-profit
corporation under rsa 292
so it i'm sorry not for prof not for
profit voluntary corporation under rsa
that is that that becomes a organized
under the state as part of the state of
new hampshire
and
and at least the concern that was uh
that was expressed um
by representative walls
and uh and it actually came through i
think some correspondence
with um with with the bar association
um or with with other members of the bar
association that that
that it's not specific enough and and
could
could potentially breach sovereign
immunity and and other things that i'm
really not
you know i really don't have the
background to speak with
but um
but that would really be i think one
objection to um to the bill as it's um
as it's presented and amended and maybe
it's something that can be uh looked at
um more carefully in the uh in the
senate but um but unfortunately i don't
think we have any more um
yeah we had discussed that
representative luno and the commissioner
of agriculture
sean jasper had taken this to the ag's
office
and they reviewed that and they said
this is fine
however it probably will need a little
bit more look at
it's kind of a above and beyond this
committee
from a policy perspective i don't see
any problem with it uh but i i i think
that what you bring up is a point that
will need to be looked at
down the road in the senate they don't
have anything to do so they can look at
that part of it
any further discussion
mr clerk
representative cordelli yes
this is fine this one's fine
this one's fine
yeah did we have a motion i didn't
hear the motion in a second i'm sorry
yeah what to pass as a men did cordelli
and hobson would that work
no
i made the motion i have that
then who made the motion
who's okay i i think i made it and who
seconded it
yeah so on that on that last one
to
approve
1164 as amended was made by my self and
second by cordelia okay
that we did have that process
i just thought that was the amendment
not the bill itself but
thank you
right that's right
all right well let me start over again
then
representative cordelli was yes
representative
notter was
yes representative johnson was yes
anybody happy thank you representative
yes representative ernst steen yes
representative
yes representative ford yes represent
representative soda
yes
representative nelson yes representative
luno yes
representative
jack yes representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes
i had it on i saw it
okay representative ellison
representative mullen
yes
representative woodcock yes
representative porter yes representative
hall yes representative ladd yes 19-0
yes
any problems with consent
not saying we'll put that on consent
next bill on the dock and we're going to
try to
mr chair just on the um on the
the committee report for consent
would it be worth at least make i will
know that i will i'll know that okay
thank you um uh going on to the next one
which we i hope is also we can get done
as 1236
relative to the legislative oversight
committee for the education improvement
and assessment program
yes and there is an amendment
do we have a motion uh
from
i'll second it
that's on the base bill do you have the
amendment dave
okay uh
yeah
so um thank you mr chair the uh the base
bill and i'm i i am going to uh or or
representative ladd will introduce
amendment 923 which replaces the base
bill but uh there's uh there's elements
of the base bill that are that are very
important
for the uh from uh basically providing
over sound oversight relativity to the
accountability of uh of of um of public
schools in new hampshire and uh
and and uh i think it um
it was it was probably an oversight that
it was that it was repealed last year
during a sort of an omnibus um statutory
repeal and a lot of stuff did need to
get sweeped up but uh this wasn't one of
them and um and so it's uh i'm i'm glad
representative ladd is bringing this
back and um and and is about to
introduce an amendment
and you know i'll just echo exactly what
representative luna said each year
uh or each
biennium uh there are there are omnibus
bills to come omnibus bills to come
forward with all the bills that we look
at the committees and commissions that
haven't been active and there's
recommendations
to get rid of them seeing we don't have
enough reps and to really get all these
things done or that really are
interested in in that task this was one
that was caught up a year ago in that
bundle
and it really needs to continue so what
this is doing it's repealing the repeal
of the
improvement and assessment oversight and
that deals with our statewide assessment
program
and where the legislature looks at the
assessment and there's a process a time
frame in which the commissioner has to
bring back to us information regarding
that how we're doing on it and if
there's changes to be made it has to
come back through that oversight group
so it's not necessarily used every year
but it is necessary that we still have
it and that group is also was very
instrumental when we went through and we
approved the esser program
uh that
is the elementary secondary education
act the most recent version of it that
had to come to that committee as well
because we were dealing with assessment
so
we need to have this thing back in the
books and we've noticed it when we've
been trying to write legislation this
year even that it doesn't exist anymore
and so um
we're trying to get it back in the books
simple
simple task but we have modified that
and the amendment will
address that
so i'd like to introduce and and
amendment
0923h
to
1236 as ought to pass
0 9 2 3 h
is there a second
thank you
um i'm not going to you know i've read
this but i prefer that if you would
speak to some of the changes we've done
reps in luno regarding committee
membership
happy too um you know
one of the reasons
excuse me
one of the reasons some um
statutory committees don't meet as often
as they should
is sometimes due to how membership is
is applied on that that committee and so
what uh what we've done in the amendment
is to have five members of the house of
representatives appointed by the speaker
of the house
and one member of the senate appointed
by the senate president as opposed to
specific members coming from specific
committees
and
and several members coming from the
senate we certainly all recognize that
that senators have have
a number of obligations outside of the
multiple committees that they already
serve on and um and getting to um
to uh work on statutory committees is
sometimes a real stretch for their for
their time so um
so we think this is a this is a better
organization for this and frankly um
allows the the five members um coming
from the house
to be representative obviously of the
composition of the political composition
of the house
and um and uh and i think puts the
speaker in a position where uh where
they can work with the um
the chair of um
of you know let's say the education
committee to recommend who those five um
members would uh would be so i think
that's a good um good improvement and
then and then a little bit of structure
in terms of how the um the meeting gets
uh organized electing a chair
and then um and then the rest of it is
really um um
uh pretty much taken from the um the the
the earlier statute in terms of what the
what the authority is to review
provisions associated with the
accountability and assessments under
193h
and um
and then uh
submitting a report legislative
oversight committee submitting a report
uh the commission will submit the submit
the report to the chairs of the house
and senate education committees so um so
a little bit of housekeeping on um on
that and uh and then i think also a nice
i think addition to this
is um is you know the sort of the
structure of the preamble here which did
not exist um in um in the in the earlier
version of this that really sort of lays
out the the the scope of um of why you
would have an oversight a legislative
oversight committee responsible for um
for looking at the accountability and
assessments of our public schools so um
i hope that um sort of sort of brings
people through what the amendment does
and i hope you'd find
be favorable to supporting the amendment
i think that does uh it's very difficult
to get senate members on committees and
commissions at times
and
this will put the bulk of the burden on
the house
one other aspect of this bill is every
four years the statewide assessment
program must be reviewed
by the commissioner
and in the past reports have been
submitted to the education committee
senate and house
without that we would you know not have
any input in terms of what we're using
as an instrument to assess where we are
with adequacy
and achievement and growth
and i i they're they're i think by
having the legislature involved
is extremely important and so i
absolutely support uh reinstating the
oversight committee and the way it is i
think it's going to be a more effective
group with the membership leaning on the
house side
reps and like us
i just have a question did section 1a
was was
did you change that or is that exactly
like it was before
1a
yes that's
that's like a purpose statement and um
reflects um
basically what what
we're doing
is there any further discussion
okay we have a
um do we i i gotta wake up here do we
have a motion on that yeah we must
yeah
and i made the motion on
okay
so i think we're good uh reps and nelson
and vote
on the amendment all those case
okay good
we're on the amendment
i wasn't done asking questions i'm sorry
nice
good
okay so now we have to look at the bill
as amended
hb 1236
the motion is ought to pass as amended
further discussion
i have further questions it was still
questions on the amendment i was still
working on that
um it says shall provide all students
but it says public
public elementary and secondary
education
i'm just trying to work this out with
things that have been going on like
does this mean
that public schools must accept all
students or
i'm trying to work through the
the
ramifications of that paragraph
currently on our statewide assessment
program if you're in a charter school or
you're being tuition to a receiving
environment of some kind
the state is required if the student so
desires to take that assessment so the
state has the dollar
allocates that dollar every year for the
state assessment to be used by all
that's the assessment i'm talking about
schools
public elementary and secondary
education shall provide all students
with the opportunity
and so what does that mean public
elementary and secondary education
that's my first thing yeah yeah that's
exactly what it means it's fairly plain
language there it has nothing to do with
with um
you know what uh what
school a student
goes to
it's basically referring to to public
elementary and secondary
education
um in new hampshire uh shall provide all
students with the opportunity to acquire
the knowledge and skills okay so it's
not talking about public schools it's
just talking about public education as
in education provided by public dollars
is that what that means
i'm just trying to make sure i
understand it
okay
all right
thank you you're welcome
further discussion
representative nelson
representative
cordelli
yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson
yes representative lucas yes
representative erstein yes
representative hopson
yes representative ford
yes representative soda
yes representative nelson yes
representative luna yes
representative jack yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison yes representative mullen yes
representative woods yes
representative porter yes representative
hall yes representative ladd yes
okay um
what was the final vote on that 19-0
any problems with consent
thank you
so we'll put that on consent
um next uh bill which we'll deal with is
hb 1255
relative to teachers loyalty
55.
represent lakers you're recognized for a
motion
i move out ito
is there a second a second
okay we have a motion made by
representing lekkas uh as uh itl and
second by rep representative cordelli uh
representative lekkis do you have any uh
discussion
yes this bill has written was
very badly written
as you've heard me say before
and i just wanted on the record that the
title teacher's loyalty has to do with
the section in law and not my title
because there's been a lot of
uh emails etc that that we're trying to
say that teachers aren't loyal etc and
it has nothing to do with that that
happened to be the title of the section
that was already in law that was being
amended
um i did come up with an amendment as i
promised i would
i it took a long time and discussion
with a lot of people both in in the
committee and outside of the committee
and it came in yesterday but the problem
is it is so different because like i
said i did not like it all the way the
bill was worded and it didn't express in
any way
the intent of the bill the new amendment
expresses the bill very nicely but it is
so different you wouldn't recognize it
as being the same and so having a
discussion on that on the day we have to
have all of our bills exact
is uh unreasonable so
i decided the best thing to do is itl
the whole thing and bring it back next
year
further discussion represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman
yes i think that this
bill started out
badly
for a number of reasons including
timing issues
timing
with
personal issues family issues
with the
prime sponsor in trying to
get the proper language in
to drafting
for the bill
never had the opportunity to
revise that original
language
which caused quite a bit of
upset and concern in in the community
i know there were repeated attempts and
discussions with people who testified on
the bill
to
update it
but
as uh
representative lakers mentioned
that we've come to the point where we're
at a deadline and so i
agree that the
best course of action is to
itl
this bill
further discussion
not seeing any hands uh
are you ready reps and nelson yes i am
sir
representative uh
why don't we
state the the motion that's a good point
it's bill 1255 no i'm sorry yes 12 55
itl
representative cordelli yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson yes representative
yes representative
erstein yes
representative hopson
yes representative ford
yes representative soto yes
representative nelson yes representative
luna yes
representative jack yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison i'm happy to vote yes on this
motion
representative mullen
yes
representative woodcock
representative porter yes representative
hall yes representative ladd yes
representative woodcock always brings a
little bit of levity to the community
here
must be that conway air
okay the next bill which we have
is
yes you may thank you um i think it's
appropriate this time i'd like to just
acknowledge uh international women's day
uh particularly where it celebrates the
social economic cultural and political
achievements of women we have so many
women in the education field i think
it's an appropriate time to make that
acknowledgment thank you oh thank you
that's yes worthy and and
my wife will appreciate that
and i'll have to bring some flowers home
okay
for all the others do the same thing
okay um the next bill which will attack
is 12.98
relative to eligibility for the
education tax credit
yes
yeah we should have done it thank you is
there any objection to consent
good it'll be on tv
okay we're on hb 1298 relative to
eligibility for the education tax credit
representative cordelia you're
recognized for a motion
thank you mr chair um i would move ought
to pass on house bill 1298
i would second thank you very much the
motions ought to pass made by cardelli
and second by lekkas
um representative cordelli do you have
any
discussion uh yes thank you
this bill is
simple
in that it changes
one number
currently in statute
and it's been that way since
the program's in inception about 10
years ago
where the household income
cap is at
currently 300 percent of the federal
poverty guidelines
same as the education freedom account
program
too often i think
in government
programs we initiate
are aimed at
lower income
families but
ignore
middle income and lower middle income
families uh this bill
raises the family income cap from 300
percent to 500 percent
we have heard um
from many people
in relation to the new education freedom
account program that
the problem they see with the program is
the income cap
this is this program the tax credit
program is based on
voluntary donations to the scholarship
program
in return for tax credit
both from businesses or individuals
with a credit against the interest and
dividends
tax that they might pay
and those
have to be approved in advance by the
department of revenue administration
those credits
so this
legislation simply increases the uh
family uh income cap
um
and i think uh after 10 years and
you know what we've seen in terms of
the uh demand and the interest in
providing some
relief and educational opportunities to
lower middle-income families
that this bill is needed
thank you further discussion
representative
thank you very much mr chair so my
understanding is that the tax credit
scholarship program actually works
within a
budget that is defined in statute is
that that's correct
um
i'm not sure about uh i can't remember a
budget specifically in statute i know
there are um the limit as terms of the
amount of tax credit that can be
obtained
and so so unlike the um the education
freedom account program which operates
without any budget at all and is
absolutely a blank check
the tax credit scholarship program does
work within a budget so i guess
my my concern here or my question here
is that will
will
will students who come from families
that earn less or equal to
the current
income eligibility threshold of 300 of
the federal poverty guideline be given
preference toward that toward that
finite
budgeted amount
or might might some of these
students from lower income families
not receive a scholarship
yet
a student that um that's from a family
of four let's say
500 i think is approximately 132 000
a year um could they receive a
scholarship over somebody that was uh
maybe from a much lower income
family or is there some sort of some
sort of
policy
in statute that that gives preference to
lower income
uh representative cordelli would you
like to respond to that thank you uh yes
thank you um for bringing that up
because i
neglected to talk about that um in my
previous remarks
but
this
increase in the income
cap
would only affect uh people if there was
a significant
increase in the
donations made to the program
i think right now the majority of people
in the program even though the cap is at
300 percent i believe the majority
or close to the majority
of families have an income cap um of 180
have an income of 185 or lower which is
the free and reduced
level so
this in effect
is uh setting the stage
for the possibility of increased uh
donations to the scholarship fund
because as of now um with the amount
that's been donated to the
scholarship fund
there is not money to provide
to families over the 300 percent income
cap so um unless there is uh an increase
in the donations
there will be no direct scholarship
impact to the increase to 500 percent
but um
i'm hopeful that um by doing this
it will
make send a message to businesses let's
say that there are more people out there
who are interested
in these scholarship opportunities and
maybe spur um additional donations to
the program
follow up on that
but um but given the fact that the the
tax credit
um is is set at a finance a finite
amount um
that that any
uh voluntary contributions from
businesses or or um
or
or persons
towards the towards the program
uh over and above the budgeted amount
would would not qualify for tax credit
is that isn't that correct
i think in order for us to respond this
is one of the areas that represent
tanner's bill would have helped us out
77 g is not in our book
there's a lot of areas which are dealing
with education which are also dealt with
other areas like in finance and all that
and so that's not in this annotated
version whereas we've had it in the past
so it's one of the areas to cut out
that's why we do need to move forward
and get that
done correctly
so it's you're going to have to find
that
section if you're looking for it on your
computer or your iphone
go ahead
no i'm not i don't know
did represent cordelia you want to
are you looking that up right now um
yeah
i believe
yeah i mean i could just state that as a
concern as well if if we um if we can't
quickly find it i i uh my
my my concern is that um is that the um
that the amount that's raised through
through
contributions
that qualify for for uh for a tax credit
is really where the uh is really where
the voluntary part you know sort of
comes to an end uh if um if if uh if if
a person or a business wants to
contribute beyond that i think that
could go towards what representative
cordelli is suggesting that that an
increase in voluntary contributions but
they would not necessarily
be
be receiving
uh the um the tax credit for those
contributions beyond what's laid out in
statute today
go ahead
thank you i will point out that we
talked uh or i mentioned briefly the
free and reduced 185 percent um it is in
statute that at least 40 of the
scholarships have to be awarded to
people um at that income level or so
that that is not changing even if the
top end cap is increasing um at least 40
percent of all scholarships have to go
to the 185 percent or lower families
further discussion representation than
representative porter
yes um
the
cap
the total cap in
legislation in law
is way higher
than the
amount that they've ever managed to get
through donations so running out of that
cap is not an issue
what can be an issue they tend to
in choosing which families because
there's limited money tends to be those
with most need so usually it is the very
poor but occasionally
there's a student who is in a situation
in a public school
who is extreme bullied
potentially special needs and bullied
because of that
who
whose family might make
you know rather than 300
but can't afford to put their kids still
because that's still not that much
can't afford to put their
child
into another a private school and they
can't find another public school for
them to go into
and so there are those occasions
it's not
it's it's rare but there are those
occasions where they do need to move a
kid
under the children's scholarship fund to
get them out of a dangerous and very bad
situation and they need to move them and
they need to have the flexibility to do
that now hopefully
donations will pick up and hopefully
this will come to that point but one of
the things you have to realize with this
percent it's the federal poverty
guidelines and everybody looks at it
like that's a lot but
new hampshire poverty and federal
poverty are two different things because
remember the cost of living like along
this in the south is a fraction of the
cost of living here so think about what
just a cheap one-room
room apartment is here
and
and how much that costs so our cost of
living is considerably higher so basing
things on the federal poverty level
doesn't accurately
describe what's actually going on in
real life if you've tried to get an
apartment lately
um any place in the southern part of the
state it's extremely expensive
and so you can be a family a lower
middle class family and barely make an
ends meet and then find that you have to
move your kid because
that your kid is is not for whatever
reason doing very badly in the local
public school and you have to move your
kid
and you can't afford it because our cost
of living is so high so
i just wanted to point that out further
questions representative porter
thank you mr chair and i'm really
pulling
back from memories from a couple of
years ago but originally when the tax
credit program
came in it only dealt with business
taxes
but several years ago and i remember
sitting volunteering on the ways and
means committee when it changed
it was allowed that interest and
dividends
taxes could also be reduced by
contributions to this fund
and that was the time when they did set
a maximum limit of how much could be
credited
what the top of the budget was
is this attempt here do you think
representative cordelli an effort to
now that the legislature has started to
reduce
interest and dividends tax with the goal
of getting rid of it all together a
whole
batch of contributors will be eliminated
so is this the goal of this to
encourage
other kinds of contributions and do you
think
i know the discussion was back then that
the businesses were contributing but not
to the degree that had been anticipated
which was one of the reasons why
interest in dividends was included so
are you hoping now that
that this will encourage other kinds of
contributions that aren't tax credit
contributions toward this fund
if i might
go ahead yeah um
i really hadn't thought of other
types of contributions to the program
other than tax credits um but i do
recognize the uh phase out of the
interest and dividends attacks which
might have
an impact on the number of an amount of
donations
um
but i in terms of my hopes
um the hopes are that
more businesses
will become aware of the program and
take advantage of the program and
provide scholarships to needy children
at the same time
representative tanner
thank you um
i have a couple of
well a couple of comments a couple
questions
first of all the median household income
in new hampshire for a family of four is
ninety seven thousand dollars and
uh a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
which i believe is what we're talking
about puts people in the 80th percentile
of income or in the top
top
15 percent of the people in new
hampshire as far as income is concerned
so just to get an idea of how this
increases
i'd like to ask that if somebody took a
education tax credit are they then
eligible for an education freedom
account as well
yes
and as a follow-up to that so they would
get approximately five thousand dollars
from that
and how much from the education tax
credit
uh when the tax credit scholarship um
program started
the uh
average um
scholarship amount was i believe 2500
um and it's in
increases with the consumer price index
annually so i'm not sure what the
maximum average scholarship is right now
so we're talking maybe
between seven thousand and eight
thousand dollars for a person that
qualifies for both
um that's that's possible i'm not sure
how many people um currently are
doing both you know maybe when
the oversight
committee for the fa program
meets again we will
be able to raise that question
further further discussion yes
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
um
i have a follow-up to representative
tanner but that wasn't my initial intent
i'll just sort of speak a minute ago
check it through my notes from our the
initial dialogue of this bill
if i recall if my notes are accurate
which they may be
it says they already have an extreme
waiting list
at the 300 level
and when we first started this bill
first thought the mission was for
low-income families
to help their students and help their
children
so if we increase the scholarship level
to 500 we aren't even
filling
the
amount of scholarship need
as it exists right now at 300 percent
and i and i have the same concern that
that
representative luna mentioned about
what's going to happen when more the
increase of level of the parental
guidelines for a financial
level at 500 percent
particularly
when we talked about the requirement of
i think glenn said forty percent for i
think those who use the quarterly forty
percent uh for the 185 guy line so that
means sixty percent of the kids uh
currently
uh are above that the one that 185 was
still below 300 and we have a waiting
list and i think that my number here
that i wrote down at the time was 600
uh when they had when they had the
testimony so my concern is
i have a i don't have a concern on
scholarships
i think they're terrific i do have a
concern the fact that we may be given
scholarship at the home the homeless
schools are already there but that's a
different issue my concern is that this
was a program based on low income
families
and three percent or 500 is around 70 80
000 it makes it low income for a family
of four and now we're going to jack that
up to
500 percent without any limit on uh the
the youngster's percentage so he's
servicing those people most needy we're
not we're providing an option for those
who are in the next level and we have a
waiting list of folks who are already
low income which was the mission of this
account so um i i'm not i'm not going to
support this moving up when we have 600
kids waiting at the 300 level i just see
it being filtered out to other
youngsters who were less than 80.
thank you chairman
further for the discussion
yes representative
as it stands now
raising it to 500
won't make any difference whatsoever
there's not enough money
and they take the neediest kids first i
had a conversation
with the children's scholarship fund and
they specifically told me it won't make
any difference now because they don't
have enough money and it's not and it's
not they're not limiting
to 40 percent the number of kids it's
not oh the law says 40 so we're doing 40
and the rest are higher no it's they're
they're taking the neediest ones first
which means
uh representative cordelli had the
actual percent
it's well over 40 percent that are still
at that low income level but what it
does is it gives that option it does two
things one is it gives that option for
that one kid
like i said that one kid who they have
to figure out what to do with who's in a
bad situation who is in extreme need and
since they're rating on need
that would be an extreme need but the
other thing is it puts it for the future
if the if
the if the money does come in it gives
them those opportunities but they will
still take the neediest first and so
even if we go all the way up to whatever
the maximum allowed is
they're going to take the neediest first
they still may never get above the 300
depending upon what need and what kids
apply
so
at any rate they told me it actually for
the moment except in that rare instance
won't make any difference anyways
because they don't have enough money
representative woodcock thank you sir
just to fall um represent legally i
understand what you're saying but that's
exactly my concern that you're a lot
they haven't met the need yet there's
nothing in the statute that i see that
says they have to take the lowest income
every time and nothing that says that
you're telling me that they they may or
they choose to except for this one
section with this one exception or this
one exception uh and then i see that
exception we have a in a large number of
rsas that allow for movement of
youngsters from one school to another
school that there is options there now
now that has nothing to do with the
finances of it that's a different option
for kids who may be in different
circumstances we have all those
regulations that do that and we have a
process for that i don't i can't i'm
concerned that using a single one
student identifying with these two
characteristics and then saying well
that one but that still moves if that
youngster is at the 500 level that there
are other youngsters at the 300 level
that aren't being serviced by
the mission of this the goal of this was
for low income families and they're not
they're not there's nothing in the law
that says they have to do it that way 40
that's it
so my concern is we're just adding to
the pile and there will be more
exceptional exception there i think
until we get to a level where all of the
youngsters who apply can be serviced we
don't need to increase the criteria
thank you chairmanland thank you the
aggregate total of tax credits that can
be
issued regarding to our taxpayers is 5.1
million dollars
and you can carry forward as a business
that's being that's
applied to your business profits tax or
your enterprise tax the most they can
carry forward is one million dollars for
four year period of time then it goes
you then it is gone my question is do we
know what the aggregate number is that
we have been receiving from as a result
of this is it is it up to the max of 5.1
million or are we down somewhere around
three or so or two i don't know
representative cordelli
according to the 2021 report
um
the total dollar donations received were
2.686 million dollars
and um
right and uh
the percentage of students um eligible
for free and reduced price
meals
was 68
of the students in the program
representative tanner
thank you i i guess um and it's kind of
a follow-up to representative woodcock's
um
uh questions and comments is that
with this program and the reason the
program was come in
was the need that people needed money
because they without the money they
didn't have
access
to
educational options
the need that you're describing as the
one student
is a need to have an option
but with a higher income
they don't
by definition don't have the need
for the
scholarship you know when when
somebody's applying to college and they
want scholarships or they're trying to
get financial aid
it's based on on
finance your financial situation
so the need should be
financial and not
necessarily the need
over and above that of having an option
because these the people that have that
type of income
have always had options and have those
options and
it doesn't stop them from going to a
private school or doing tutors or
whatever they
would like to do
and so
that's one comment i have and the other
comment i have is if it's not needed
right now why are we doing this
representative cardelli
yes
as i think i tried to indicate earlier
i i believe that this will send a
message
both to the
business community
that
these scholarships are an opportunity
to help children and it's something they
should
look more closely at
i think that there can be
a lot more
publicity
awareness in the business community
about the program
itself
so i think that this will help to
focus that attention
um
and
you know really
tell
all families that uh
we care about uh education and that um
you know we're doing our best to provide
for uh for all children um in the state
representative
ellison and then representative
uh thank you mr chair i i guess the
question is to
representative cordelli
based on the the numbers that you gave
us about
sort of last year and expenditures you
said 68
of the the students receiving assistance
were free
met that free and reduced price lunch
185 percent is that am i correct
are there other students who are
applying for the program
who meet that criteria who did not get
grants
um
i i don't have that information but i
think that the
intent is to provide for those uh lower
income students but i i don't have any
hard numbers as to
maybe other students
uh just to add a little bit more to that
the
organization the business that's
contributing they can contribute uh 80
they get uh 85
of that contribution is that tax
deduction
if we have
2.6 million dollars which we've heard
there's capability of getting another
2.5 million dollars which would if with
that money coming into this system
and
we're getting to that aggregate of 5.1
there's more opportunity for these
children to have this opportunity the
money would be there i think what
representative cortelli was speaking to
is that
um
by
if we can do some better marketing maybe
on this program
uh we can get more involvement so that
we're able to help all those children
need this assistance
representatives and then follow the
other i just wanted to respond that that
one student
had
financial needs because as i said
it costs more here than it does
elsewhere and it's based on national
numbers and sometimes
i mean they're not going to give money
to a kid who doesn't need money
they're giving money to a kid who needs
money and it's proud don't assume it's
500 it might be 305.
i know i was hearing about one who was
just over the 300 limit but the family
didn't have the money and had an
immediate need
and are you going to tell a kid who's
being bullied who's who's in who's
threatening to take his life
over it and has to get out of the school
that he has to stay there because his
parents make 305 percent of the limit or
350 percent of the limit and his parents
can't put him in another school they
don't have the money they don't have the
resources but i'm sorry you're over the
limit you got to go back to that school
where
you know
where you're making
any rate i don't even want to think
about what will happen to them
woodcock and then we're going to have to
bring this discussion to us
i may have missed this during the
initial discussion i didn't write it
down i know it's either you or grandma
no is there uh rather than cordelia
is there a was there a balance left in
that account
last year at the end of the 2021 i i
believe there was an amount carried
forward about how much um
uh i think he said representative up
allowable a million but i just
i don't know what it was
well that that yeah the they're able to
keep credits that they haven't used for
four years okay
yeah the businesses okay right five
million right
okay
thank you um
in that particular account
representative cordelia
it was there a balance at the end of the
year
i'm just trying i'm just trying to weigh
we have all these youngsters
we have all these youngsters who
according to the when they made the
testimony did not get serviced
uh waiting list
and i'm just trying to decide if they
zeroed out the account they still have
money left they account
i i i believe that they provide
scholarships to the best of the their
ability based on the funding
do they have do they have money left in
the budget at the end of the year
oh we don't know that
refs and lucas
they get money in on a regular basis so
they were zeroed out many times during
the year i don't actually know whether
they got money
right at the end and had some carryover
i know they would be zeroed out and then
they'd put notice out to families to say
we got more money we can provide you
some money now
and um it's not unusual for money to
come in at the end
so they they may well have had some at
the end but that doesn't mean they had
it earlier
thank you thank you chairman thank you
thank you represent luna
sure thank you very much mr chair um i'm
really encouraged that uh that that
there's so many people that seem to um
recognize how important um spending um
5.1 million dollars
in
in what in tax credit dollars so you
know without the state business profits
tax we would not have this program so
clearly these are otherwise tax tax
dollars
um and uh and 5.1 million dollars for
604 uh for students uh i'm aware that uh
that there's an effort in the senate to
um
to also provide
some some support for communities that
have higher numbers of students that
come from low-income backgrounds
or or have low property valuations and
so i believe the senate has put 14
million dollars for a program that
supports 160 000 students
so um so i i certainly hope as as this
committee and as the legislature in
general looks to uh to get real in terms
of how the state funds its public
schools that it will um it will look at
ratios
like what we're seeing here
in terms of the generosity from the
state in supporting students educational
needs and applying it beyond just 600
kids and are probably applied to the 160
000 kids that we have statewide thank
you but we need to be reminded that
there's also the business bet
that this money is not state money the
credit is on the other side the coin and
remains with the business
and so it's not revenue comes into our
our general fund or trust fund any of
that so there is a a line there uh so
we're not subtracting from our our
regular budget
no no rick
we are subtracting from the regular
budget because the tax credit is clearly
a subtraction from business profits or
business enterprise tax paid you pay you
pay whichever is greater your business
enterprise tax or your business profits
tax that's how it works in uh in new
hampshire and uh i'm actually a little
shocked to learn that with the tax
credit program you have a four-year
carry forward where where where
businesses do not have any potential for
loss carry forward with business profits
taxes in new hampshire as they do in the
in the federal tax law so it's
surprising to me that but you know that
obviously the structure of the tax
credit
program goes beyond what we're what
we're debating this morning but uh but
it's uh it's it's very clear that
without our business
tax structure in new hampshire that this
program would not exist at all
last last discussion and then we're
going to move on
there are numerous people who give money
and have given money to that program
myself included four years with no
write-off whatsoever
number one and number two i have heard
businesses who give money to that who
have said that is my money i choose
where that money goes and i could put it
into a different tax credit if i wanted
to
it is not public money it is my personal
money
that this is testimony that i have heard
on this bill in past years
well not this bill but on this on this
uh scholarship
and according to
the supreme court it is not state money
it is private money and so
i just want to make sure that you
understand this is not state money it's
been ruled it and the businesses can
give it wherever they want they can give
it to a different tax credit it is their
money thank you okay we need to move on
here we got a lot of bills on the docket
for today
um
so uh
mr clerk would you please uh call the
bill number and and call the roll that
the
the bill is ought to pass on
what the 1298 12-98
who's in sight of the number of the bill
representative cordelli yes
representative nutter yes
representative johnson yes
representative lakers yes representative
bern erstein yes representative hopson
yes representative ford yes
representative soda yes representative
nelson yes
representative luna no
representative jack no
representative cornell
representative tanner no representative
ellison no representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter no representative
hall no
representative vlad
yes
[Music]
so i put down represent woodcock's name
yes okay so let me understand what you
want the minority report will be done by
a combination of represent luna and
woodcock but it'd be on woodcock's name
okay
you got it
and i
assume that representative cordelia be
doing the other one okay
good
all righty uh moving on down through
some bills here
um
looking for something that
any more easy ones
but which one is this now dave
okay so what yeah the 28a which was what
that one
1190. so okay we'll hit 11.90
uh this is relative to rulemaking by the
state board of education for compliance
with federal provisions
do we have any amendments on that one at
all
i don't think so okay uh
representative hobson
i'd like to make a motion to ought to
pass
and second hi second so we have a motion
made by representing hobson second by
representative lekkis as otp on hb 1190.
uh further discussion from the maker of
the motion
yes um so
improper funding of state mandates in
new hampshire violates our new hampshire
constitution under part first bill of
rights article 28a
these programs become local taxpayer
responsibilities with only a rising
property tax bill to let
constituents know that the programs even
exist
i think we can and should do better for
our constituents let's hold the federal
government to the same standards we hold
ourselves
this measure
does not oppose federal government but
does tell the state board they cannot
create rules where there is a lack of
federal funding similar bills have been
heard in the education committee and
this committee has also voted down
federal legislation that could not be
fully funded
thank you representatives
as you hear from me all so often 28a
violation
this is what ends up happening we adopt
these federal we take this federal money
we adopt these federal rules and the
schools end up having to pay for it
without us providing the funding thank
you
further discussion from the committee
rep san luna thank you very much mr
chair so um you know as we as we heard
um uh
the uh the the state does have to have
to comply with uh with federal laws
and uh and just saying that while we
refuse to do rules to comply with
federal laws only will put us in
non-compliance with federal laws which
have other strings attacks attached to
it like like potentially idea funds like
like potentially title one dollars like
potentially federal highway dollars so
all i can tell
is uh for the best of it this is a
feel-good bill uh at best
for um
uh for the people who are who are the
proponents of this but um but at worst
uh this could potentially force the
department of education to uh to
dismantle special education laws uh that
are consistent with uh with uh with
federal requirements and uh and could
could potentially have devastating
effects at least on the the rules that
um that are that are uh uh developed by
the uh by the department uh but uh you
know uh that said that will not
for a second change new hampshire's
obligation to um uh to meet uh and to
perform against the uh
uh the requirements that uh that that
come to us through the uh the us
department of of education
and um and so you know i really i
th this this bill
really doesn't accomplish anything that
that i think the sponsors um
um
intend to to happen but could certainly
have um have uh ill effects
um particularly uh on our special
education
student population thank you
further discussion
yes represent hobson
yes i just wanted to simply point out
that
for instance the bill that we heard
about the national school lunch program
it was basically coming down to
instituting an entire program and
infrastructure
positions to oversee this program for 30
schools that
had not already implemented their own
breakfast program
so
it's fine to get grant money to
establish the program but it's incumbent
on the taxpayers to keep the program
going and they don't even know that this
is happening and that's the reason for
this bill we need to be more responsible
to taxpayers
further discussion
representative porter
thank you mr chair um i just made my
memory refreshed does anybody know
what percentage of the employees at the
department of education
are funded by federal funds somewhere
around 80 85 percent
thank you
that's about 200
president woodcock
thank you i just wanted to clarify a
fact that we dealt uh the representative
hudson uh may have mistakenly uh
said i knew she wouldn't do it on
purpose uh
the 30 schools
i'm talking back to the breakfast lunch
programs you just mentioned the one that
was cost 40 cents a day for a student
have a breakfast and lunch if they're on
a free reducing that program um
the 30 schools
were not 30 schools that
currently uh are regulated the 30 school
number that you hear from does uh 30
schools that currently do not uh
participate
in the coe program with the federal
funding so they don't know uh which 30
schools they that who participate
because they open this bank so it
doesn't cost those 30 schools anything
because they aren't in the program and
that wouldn't do that that's where that
30 number comes from uh there are some
schools however that that you i think
you're alluding to that take you just
only breakfast at lunch and don't do
breakfast which would be the cost it
wasn't those thirty those thirty are all
by the south on an island thank you
further discussion representative tanner
thank you um
i fully support
representative lou knows comments that
this is going to hurt the disabilities
people in the state of new hampshire
has that potential but i'd also like to
point out that the hypocrisy
of 28a and also the little l that's put
on our
bills speaking for local financial
impact and also our constant use of
local control
when it's
advantageous to us and so is 28a used
there are so many things that are
put into law in the state of new
hampshire
that
do not have the funding
with them
and
we do so because there's a need or
because we feel that it's important and
the state can support it so
i just think again this is just a
feel-good bill thanks
further discussion representative hobson
thank you i just want to follow up on
rep tanner's comments that i completely
agree
we need to be responsible
for everything that we implement in the
state everything
okay if there's no further discussion
we'll call the roll and
move forward
bill 1190 ought to pass
representative cordelli
yes representative notter yes
representative johnson yes
representative lucas yes representatives
firsting yes representative hopson
yes representative ford
yes
representative soda yes representative
nelson
yes
representative jack no
no i apologize no representative jack no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no representative
ellison no representative mullen no
representative woodscock no
representative porter no
representative hall no and
representative vlad
in his mind
yeah yes
hey you know
i apologize for
all the the nicknames we've had here you
know
but it's catching isn't it
it's fun
okay um
so the minority report is done by
representative porter
and the majority report will be done by
reps and hobson we're going to take a
break here and come back at quarter of
so folks can walk down the hallway if
they have to get a drink of water et
cetera
and we'll come back and start in about
seven minutes
stretch
that's what all the doctors tell us
the votes from yesterday the charter
clear
oh
was here yesterday to
get the votes to send to the office i
don't know but that's beyond my pay
great deal yeah
the republicans were all together oh
yeah
thank you
hmm
what do we got 13 or 14 more
did something like that
um
is
you
okay we gotta get going here
five minutes becomes
20 minutes
oliver would you please go in the
hallway and see if there's anybody out
there that invite them in please
invite them
maybe uh
roping time
you
okay we're going to go ahead we're
jumping around through our docket here
we're going to hit 1513 next
relative to the definition of a child
with a disability for the purposes of
special education so turn to 1513.
ugh
do you guys have the amendment there
yeah
okay
does everybody here happen
okay we're going to be passing around an
amendment for this bill
okay so we have several amendments here
on this bill 1513.
there's one that's zero nine nine three
h uh that's just a one liner that's
changing the effective date of the bill
to july one two thousand twenty three
the other amendment is zero three zero
seven h
and this is the bill where we're dealing
with special ed education where we have
the age 21
and we were looking at inclusive through
the
age 21 before they lose all the services
so they turn
21 halfway through the school year it's
the pro the child ends up having to
either you know there's no more funding
or else we'll have the funding continue
through the end of the year
so um let's have a little bit of
discussion first on these two two bills
and see if it's um
it looks like
the effective date on the zero three
zero seven h is the same date as
as um as that amendment
so let's look at uh zero three zero
seven h uh not with a motion on the
floor let's talk about it and see where
we are
reblad do you happen to have any extra
copies of that amendment
are there any anywhere 307 you're
looking for
it would be 307.
they were distributed yesterday
so
i don't have any more here either
which amendment are you starting with
she's going to make some copies now for
everybody
okay we can go ahead with the
with the discussion yes
on on three zero seven uh discussion
represent uh mullen do you wanna go
ahead please i would be happy to thank
you uh mr chairman so
this bill in uh when it came to us
originally was uh to change the
definition of who
a child eligible for services what the
age parameters are
the original bill went with the federal
definition of child with a disability
being defined as a child between the
ages of 3 and 21 inclusive
which meant that we would be adding an
extra year of service
but
we would still have the same problem of
students being booted out when they
turned a certain age
so
under federal law that age is currently
22 when a student turns the age of 22
they
are no longer eligible to be in the
program
in new hampshire it's 21.
in both of those circumstances it means
that a child who turns a particular age
in november or march or whatever could
in fact be asked to
discontinue attending school at that
time because they had aged out this
amendment uh changes the original bills
on line six and seven
from uh
in the original bill it's line four from
the age of three in 21 inclusive to
between the ages of three and the age
attained at the end of the school
calendar year during which the student
turns 21.
so that is the change that is made and
as representative ladd mentioned it also
changes the effective date to july 1
what this would allow school districts
to do
is to budget for extending the services
of a student who is turning 21 during
the school year to the end of that
school year rather than to the day that
they turned 21.
it's a compromise between the
federal definition which gave an extra
year of service but still had a student
terminating
services midway through the school year
in some cases
it's a compromise between that happening
at the age of 22 or that happening
following the 21st birthday
okay thank you very much uh
representatives
you did exactly what i was wanting to do
as far as the end of that the age
attained at the end of the school
calendar year during which student turns
age 21 that's awesome thank you for
doing that uh the problem with
and and i'm not going to blame this on
you because i don't know who actually
did the
actual wording when the bill comes out
because we know how that goes
[Music]
but reading the first part it's now
it was taken just the part between the
ages of and so between the ages of three
well between doesn't include three so
now we've lost the early end
and then down at below
um
person between the ages of 18 the age
attained we lost a word when we crossed
out 221 so
it's a wonderful intent but whoever
ended up finally wording it didn't um
edit it
right
sorry
can and can we just is that something we
can do today just fix that little
bit to make sure that we're still
including three
and
i think down below where we crossed out
221 it should say and
are you getting what i'm getting
this is the amendment this is the
amendment
0307 right that's the amendment we're
looking at right i'm not i'm not certain
why between the ages of three and
whatever that would begin at the age of
three
well
i guess mathematically it begins at four
but
no because between i know
you would say from the age of three if
you wanted to include three because the
numbers between three and eighteen are
four through seventeen
but at any rate
uh you can but the down below on line 15
you see where it's crossed out 221 but
there's no word to replace it
and you
needed an and or something needed to
or leave the two in or
because right now it says between the
ages of 18
that looks to me to be a clerical error
that's what i'm saying whoever actually
ended up writing up the amendment that's
why i said i'm not blaming this on you
i'm just saying
that there's just
technical things
not because i love what you did
yeah i guess the question would be and i
don't know the answer to that whether or
not the word and can be uh
requested as a
that can be requested
but what we can do is that
that that yeah but that's a process
which we went through already this year
if we have an hour or two
which we do have we can get this quickly
changed over there come back and send it
in in the fashion we want it sent i
would you know i hesitate in trying to
get you know let's go with this as it is
and then
then we get nailed with all the other
stuff
let's try and address now specifically
where this has to be changed and how we
want it done and then we can send it
over to them
um is the first day uh area on in lines
six and seven okay
can can we change it to from the age of
three to the age
attained just to make it really clear
that we are including three
so we don't have any objections okay
the uh original bill
uses the word between because it says
inclusive
and since inclusive got left out it
changes the meaning and that's
you know and that's why i said that's
the problem when you're copying from one
to another okay let's just copy right
let's jump down to 15 and 16.
is that
15 and 16 15 would be amended to read
person between the ages of 18 and and
the age attained at the end of the
school calendar year during which the
student turns 21.
representative can you take care of that
for us yes i would be happy to do that
thank you thank you so much
what we we should do is get this we
won't kick any
jen can you help us out here please
um we need to get this changed here and
we want to keep on marching down this
list of laundry lists we have we have
several minor changes to this amendment
we
need to get it we can do it by way of
sending it over way electronically to
them
i can give you this right here it shows
the changes
i made the
representative
i made the changes on mine i can hand it
to her
we got it too
okay here's from the age of
from
the age of and then down here of 18 and
the age
okay great yep
okay
why don't you go talk to jen in the
hallway
okay
so we're gonna
do you have some of the bills which you
wanna we we should try to tackle next
get them done before
yeah this is on hold
we we did not we don't have a motion put
forth
so we're good to go
1663 right now
this bill is relative to requirements
for home education students
1663 there's an amendment coming around
i'm sorry
okay
mr chair is there a new amendment coming
for this one there is one coming around
yes
now 1663
we had that was one of the bills which
we took up briefly yesterday along with
11 31
and
[Music]
did we take back did the makers of the
amendment take 0 398 back
we recessed it did we have a motion on
the floor i'm trying to recall
ought to pass do we have otpa
we haven't gone with the amendment yet
ok
0398h
was
it was no emotion was made we just
talked about it
tell us what happened
i have that motion sought to pass 10 to
on that amendment yeah yeah
and we went on to
0.973
ought to pass
but no vote
no
and was that
motion withdrawn or were we still
was there a motion on the floor for zero
nine seven three h and if so
okay
okay so the maker of the motion is going
to withdraw that
so we're back now to
what happened to zero three nine eight
that amen
that's what we're dealing with then now
okay so
yes representative cordelli
uh yes thank you um
in the discussion and the vote um on uh
amendment 0 3 9 8 h
i believe that there were several
issues
that
were brought to light um
and that caused some people problems and
hence the ten nine vote
um
the moment the actually the amendment
that um just passed out 10 15 h
um
works off of
0.398 but removes
section 6
um
and eight
from the amendment
which has the effect
of
um
removing the repeal
of the home education rules
that is
stricken
and then the new section
related to school attendance on lines 11
through 15
on page two of the amendment
in which it discusses um
in
homeschool student enrolling in a public
school
should be placed according to their age
that section is
removed also so it refer
reverts back to current law
um in that regard
so i think those were the two
uh things accomplished in amendment 2 10
15.
okay
so now we have is um a new amendment in
front of us
which we need to discuss
so uh mr chairman see we
yeah where did it come from
yes
i believe if i understand the
parliamentary situation you've already
passed an amendment on this bill
uh therefore
i would move reconsideration on that
amendment recommend a yes vote and a no
vote on that amendment
and then that will reset us back to
being able to consider this amendment
without having previously passed an
amendment
that puts us on that's right new ground
so first action would be to reconsider
i move that the committee reconsider its
action on amendment 3
okay yeah whatever it is
three nine eight eight and recommend a
yes vote and then and then a no vote on
the reconsideration
okay so uh would somebody like to are
you putting that motion forward
okay so we have a motion for
reconsideration on zero three nine eight
h
sir second
second okay so now we have all those in
favor
hand vote to reconsider just put your
hand up that's okay so
okay now we're into that now
um so we've approved the reconsideration
now uh let's vote on zero three nine
eight h
or down
and
so we we need to have a motion put
forward
represent cordelia do you want to make a
motion
yes i'd move uh
again it'll
on amendment
nine eight h yes uh is there a second
okay good representative makes that
second
so now we're looking at that amendment
to get that offer plate as well
this is 412 1663
thank you so okay we have a motion the
floor right now to itl amendment 0398
h
all those in favor put their hand up so
we just get this going thank you very
much that's unanimous so now we're back
on the playing field
that's right we're back on 1663
and there was a motion on 1663 initially
otp
so now we're
open for a discussion and
bringing forth another amendment
representative cordelli
yeah
um move uh ought to pass on amendment 10
15.
okay we have a motion to
ot
to approve the amendment 1015 h2 hb
is there a second
okay
women women
yeah okay we got a second so now we have
so so
that was like us so now we have
discussion
yeah see this that's
okay so we're in discussion now looking
at this amendment
1663 has been moved
further discussion on it compare it with
1663 now that's what we're comparing it
against representative mullen
representative cordelli on the amendment
thank you mr chair for
acknowledging me um on the amendment um
did i hear you
when you introduced this did i hear you
say that
the
rule-making uh repeal for the state
board of education was not in this
amendment
i'm sorry if i said that the this
amendment removes
the repeal
of the rulemaking
but i'm looking uh if you look at page 2
on line 12
is that not the repeal
i think they left it in there
section six and seven i think both were
left in inadvertently in the uh yeah it
looks good
and seven right yes
yep
and then i think we're good
then i think that's exactly what we
talked about that's exactly what we need
to do we need to take part six and seven
out of this thing
and leave the rule making place
well another bill we're gonna have to
get an amendment made
so what we'll do is um
well we can show you right here let me
check on one thing
all right let me back up here for a
second
we can reconsider
we eliminated all the previous
amendments that's gone
let's just draw a line right through the
whole thing it never happened
okay
you don't have to that just never
happens
10 15.
you
we're going to come back to 1663 we're
going to work on that at noon time
get an amendment made and come back and
and try to tackle it again
uh so right now we're going to jump to
hb 1499. this is relative to charter
public school eligibility for state
school building aid
represent hobson
i'd like to make to i'd like to make a
motion ought to pass
as amended
well
we're just going for the ought to pass
right
now did we we didn't have 14.99 on the
table before
or it's not on the table so so we got to
start from scratch ought to pass what
you're looking for right now
i do have an amendment would you like to
get that in discussion okay
is there a second to ought to pass
representatives
okay
now we are going to come back and do you
have any discussion regarding your ought
to pass motion
yes i do
uh
honorable colleagues um i'm here to
present well i this i i wrote it as uh i
was going to present my amendment
but what 1499 uh seeks to do
no i can i pass out
yeah yeah okay that's what i want
here we go
and i'm sorry there are no holes in that
amendment
in more ways than one
that's okay you can just join the rest
of the clutter on my desk here
okay go ahead uh you have the floor
represent hobson
yes can we just get a chance to get it
yeah thank you
it's right down there now
thank you
okay go ahead reps and hobson take us
right down through the bill please okay
so the amendment all right so
uh i'm here to present um an amendment
to hb 1499 after recommendations from
our hearing last month
uh 1499 relative to charter do we want
to have a second on the
okay reference lectures
and so go ahead now
relative to chartered public school
eligibility to state school building aid
this bill adds chartered public schools
to the procedures for consideration
approval plan requirements and
determination of grants to school for
school building aid
this legislation
simply repeals section 10 of 194 colon
b11 prohibiting charter schools from
receiving school building aid and adds
that revision language through the
throughout the statute where applicable
the importance of
of building aid cannot be understated
building aid is defined by the new
hampshire department of education
website as a program authorized by rsa
198 colon 15-a
through which the state provides
financial assistance to local districts
to the
to for the construction
or substantial renovation to educational
facilities for grades k through 12.
the building aids statute does not
prohibit charter schools from getting
building aid however rsa 194
rsa 194 prohibits charter schools from
getting building aid we need to adjust
this rsa
in 2021 hb 278 passed the house allowing
first right to refuse district
facilities for chartered public schools
this was a great first step however
there are additional factors that lead
us to believe
more should be done in this area for
instance we have learned in many states
that
i'm sorry my glasses are really
bothering me
in many states that district districts
frequently will not declare excess space
if they think a charter may benefit
moreover it's extremely difficult for
the state to enforce a definite a
definition of excess space just as
importantly districts frequently declare
buildings surplus because they can
require sufficient upgrades
maintenance issues code violations and
cosmetic reservations top the list for
anyone that decides to purchase the
space these and other concerns would
need to be addressed before they can be
a good fit for a growing charter school
the vast majority of charters currently
lease space because they cannot afford
significant renovations for any
buildings that's
not just surplus district buildings
on their operating budgets the ability
to own their own buildings and access to
financing is cost prohibitive
we learned from the last survey of
charter facilities
the lack of
facilities funding hurts students in two
ways
students won't have access to kitchens
libraries and science labs
lack of funding forces charter public
schools to use operational funding to
pay for the building therefore taking
away from program funding
the hearing for fort
hb1499 we learned two changes that could
make this measure stronger and as a
result i will be introducing amendment
1011h
it incorporates the statute amy clark
suggested in her testimony which is rsa
198 15 colon 15b
roman numeral 1 a
2 c in sections
1 and 2a of the bill adding public
charter schools to all pertinent areas
of the statute and repealing section 10
that prohibits charter
prohibits public charter schools from
receiving building aid
additionally the amendment clarifies who
owns the building
that's question that we all had related
to school building aid
during the hearing we also learned that
charter schools serve twice the number
of children in poverty that three
public charter schools currently own
their own building two public charter
schools currently
owned by foundations that leads back to
the school and one public charter school
owns the property and would like to
build one
that's my testimony
thank you very much
uh represent like us you were the second
do you have any further information to
add it's open to the floor for
discussion representative porter
thank you mr chair and i'm not familiar
as they should be with building aid
situation but
if a charter school gets building aid
from the state and then
in years
subsequent years
needs to close for a lack of
attendance or funding what happens to
the building aid and who's responsible
for paying it back
so anybody on the committee that has
that
response
yes i believe that's mentioned in the
amendment
can you direct us to a line please
i want to say
oh yeah section uh roman numeral 2 dash
a16
so
mr chair yes so is re representative
porter's question about um
the uh the if if uh if a charter um
terminates while it um
uh is in the uh the payment um
yes that's my question what happens if
if
situations change five years down the
road and they're no longer there but
they still owe building aid money to the
state right
to follow that up the the building aid
for a regular public school
uh if you shut that plant down within 20
years you pay it back
that's in
law so i guess we're looking for a
similar type scenario here what happens
when the charter shuts down
do they have to be accountable to the
same language as every other
receiver of public aid has to a public
school aide has to
abide by
yes thank you mr chair another uh
question that came up during the um
during the the hearing on the the bill
is introduced
um is pursuant to section two
uh
paragraph c in section two
which is how the department goes about
uh calculating
uh what the aid percentage is between
that thirty and sixty percent
of cost of eligible cost of construction
and for um
for school districts i believe the
department use equalized valuation
property valuation
slash medium family income
right right
and uh and so with charters obviously
charters can accept students from
from all across the state and from out
of state
as long as there's no waiting list of
in-state students
so
so how they would go about calculating
that
is um
you know it it is in statute where it
comes to public school districts
but it's it's um i think it's an open
question
as it relates to charters and also as it
relates to conversion
charters
further discussion representative hobson
yes i believe that the dissolution
instructions are written into the
charter program document the charter
school documents
now i think what represent luna is
addressing is that
the the amount of money that you receive
through the school building aid program
currently establishes a percentage based
upon there's several ways of doing it
you also maybe a district has multiple
districts within and you're going to get
another five percent account on top of
that but
it should it's up to a certain
percentage of the cost of that grant
total cost
what is the percentage that is there a
percentage or do they get a hundred
percent
of what they're requesting and i i don't
think that's going to be possible with
we only have 50 million dollars to begin
with
of which
i know i'm taking a guess 32 million
dollars is paying off yes that's the
tail so we have 18 million available
um
for the entire state
okay i was speaking to rep porter's
question but as far as the reimbursement
uh formula i i know that was an issue to
you we do have someone in the audience
who can speak uh directly to that if you
allow
his testimony
uh mr bill phillips
bill do you have something to add to
this
yes come on up
you have to
yeah you're on now the red all right
thank you
uh representative luna your question is
answered in um line nine of the of the
amendment
that
rsa 198
um that goes directly to a line that
basically says the reimbursement rate is
there's um which is as you know the
lowest one so it would it it is the
i think you have no risk of overpayment
excuse me mr phillips um
it's it's amended in section
two of the uh of the bill
and this is inserted by section two this
is the following
so so does this amendment then
not contain the changes that are in
paragraph c
on page two
of the bill because it doesn't use
by replacing it as inserted by section
two
is
yeah yeah so so the
the bill is introduced on page two lines
three through six
expand that thirty percent to be uh a
range between thirty and sixty percent
um and would direct the state board to
develop criteria on how to determine
that as opposed to what's what's in
there for school districts which is very
specific um based on based on equalized
valuation and uh and at median uh median
income um so i guess the question is is
that paragraph c
would that be part of
the amended bill
uh it's unclear to me
how it reads on line 21
what
it looks like what line 21 is saying is
just the 2a
part gets changed
as it was inserted by section 2 of the
bill
i don't think it's replacing section two
with
representative you're framing the the
problem correctly the original the
original bill
gave the range of repayments right
and the department at that time said it
would be very hard for them to calculate
so
representative mooney with the
department had agreed to just let's just
stick to one set number
that number being 30 percent
the in the amendment
line 9 which speaks to 198 1a2c
goes directly to basically states
charter schools shall be eligible for 30
percent
that that line is supposed to fix the
problem you're citing no no i understand
that but the amendment doesn't
doesn't take out paragraph c
from the bill is introduced because the
what the amendment on line 21 says is
remain
amend rsa blah blah blah blah a as
inserted by section 2 of the bill by
replacing it with the following so it
only
amends
from the bill lines 15 through 28 and
does not make any changes to the bill is
introduced on lines 29 on page one
going through uh
line six on page two
that's how i read that but
um
yeah i honestly i can't speak to it
it's supposed to correct that issue to
be clear though i understand what you're
saying
so so
yeah but it doesn't
i think the the the language the
language would have to read
replace section two of the bill with the
following
is that right marty
it sounded like you were
you see what i was saying
i'm not clear on where you're going to
come up with 30 percent as the figure
that's used
i've got to open up the statue
uh yeah that's that's it's 30 to 60 and
then there's different formulas we have
within current law i'm familiar with
those
for patreon
as i read this
it's okay
but that's just my opinion
mr chairman if i might
yeah
the the original bill
amends
sections a through c
that's on line 13 of the original bill
and the amendment
amends a as inserted by section two by
replacing it with the following
and that language
i'm i'm not a drafting attorney but that
language would seem to leave
sections b and c as amended by the
original bill
as they were
amended by the original bill
yeah and see we want to reflect the
statute that we have right now
i understand i think representative luna
was arguing that um
c needs to be pulled
that the that the
the amendment um
on line nine
needs to first pull those the
whole c
so i'm i'm i'm i'm arguing that mr
phillips i'm also i i think the the um
the the language of the bill and the
amendment is ambiguous as it applies to
to charter conversion charter schools
which are property of a school district
but they are also charter schools
and um
and and then i think
i think representative porter's question
is um is is very significant in terms of
what a what a charter school would do
to make sure that it um it was it would
be able to pay back
the the gr the building aid grant to the
state if they were to terminate within
20 years of of the um of the grant being
issued because school districts
obviously are our political subdivision
and have access to the resources to to
do that
charters would would i think have to
probably
have a surety bond or something that
would um that would uh allow them to
guarantee performance uh uh against that
against that provision um i don't know
how else they would i don't know
bond is the right term but have have
some sort of instrument in place that
would guarantee performance um uh with
that provision
um
so it's a it's a complicated area for
sure and um
but i but i um i i compliment
representative hobson for for looking to
you know address i think some of the
points that that that did come up um
during the hearing mr chairman may i
actually um answer that one piece
representative hopson
um is correct in her answer to
representative porter
in that
if you recall from the last hearing it
was the who owns the building what
happens if
the charter fails
the language inserted here
pointed out that the charter has to have
a dissolution agreement with the
um
the department and therefore the state
board of education
the their
the department could can do a couple
things
um
my thought originally been i'm going to
add to your thought because i actually
you make a good point my thought was
originally what they could do
was in the dissolution agreement forced
the school
to the the closing school to sell the
building and therefore pay back
the bonders and the state
so that's i mean that's how you could
enforce that penalty
dissolution agreement could also
actually include the request for a
surety bond i hadn't thought of that but
that's that's that that's how you could
get at that so the language
in the amendment
which requires a dissolution agreement
could cover what representative
luna is
suggesting and actually does answer
representative porter's question
where does it uh
address the dissolution agreement in
this amendment
um
it is uh it's line 16
it through
um 19
in partic so it's subject to a plan for
disposition i'm sorry disposition is uh
dissolution yes sorry yeah okay
and that language on 194 actually
specifically talks about how a charter
has to have a
an arrangement to dispose of assets
chairman
yes
is it okay if i ask you
this total sure thank you um i've been
here lost on this z part of the exactly
what you're speaking right now because
i'm sure it's my lack of knowledge of
reading the regulations but as i look at
the z section which is on line 19 which
we just referenced in the amendment yep
uh and on our yellow books the
non-annotated ones it's 587 h587
on the right hand side goes to the z
and i read through and i read through
that
because quote
and then i write down i don't and it
says
it says uh it doesn't say anything
uh the charter public schools including
disposition of assets shall amend the
program
amendment of his program plan but it
doesn't and i just kept on writing
through it two or three times i don't
see anything that talks about
the the solution in terms of the
the question on hand so the mic can you
explain why i'm lost
i can help you get
um
it's a little hard to do without reading
that yeah
do you understand why i'm lost or glenn
i don't get it yeah if i could army all
right
um looking at z
the way i i read it um
it's uh
there has to be a provision for
dissolution
of the
of its assets of its assets
and that would be the
school building that was
subject to
building aid
i finally hear what you're saying i'm
still lost
i i hear what you're saying i just need
i it must be my level i just need some
more clarity
okay so you said 587. yes sir on the
right hand side about
two inches down item z
which is quoted on line 19 of uh
yeah um so so provision for dissolution
of the chartered public school including
disposition of its assets
or amendment of its program plan right
so disposition of its assets would be
the in this case would be the building
right
but i don't okay but i don't see where
it
doesn't tell you how it's going to do
that it doesn't tell you how it's going
to look and i don't see anything
delineated below on
on the building or the refinancing
i agree it doesn't tell you but that
literally that's what you let the
department do that they actually in the
event of a closure the school shall
sell its assets and and reimburse its
its bondholders and the state i mean
literally i i don't think you want to be
any more specific than that
at least
sure you do
well we don't want to get into a debate
here on that right today
just
remember why can you finish that yes i
mean one of the three of four of you
they just
and the last line of 19 serves it says
as approved by the state board of
education
but
but that's this hasn't been pre-approved
this disillusion plan is not
pre-approved right
so
look at the top up at roman two
because z is just part of a list
i am i
did i don't i i did
if i could miss you all right i just i
just ain't confused thank you thank you
cordelia
um yes i uh have in my notes from the
hearing that dr greene of the department
indicated the charter has to have a
dissolution plan which is approved by
the department correct so that plan
according to z
would include dissolution of any assets
such as the building that was subject to
building aid
agreed
but does it have it for debt
got for assets but do you have it for
debt
i assume that would be part of the
dissolution plan
right but but mr chair yes you know
school districts are required to pay
back the state grant if they dissolve or
or
within within a 20-year period of time
following the the grant this doesn't
work it just requires them to have a
plan it doesn't necessarily have them
require them to have a plan
to uh to pay back the state
and uh if that's simply being left up to
the department i think that becomes very
contingent upon who you know the the
it's left up to the commissioner but in
fact it's our obligation as the
legislature to protect taxpayer money
which are used to pay these grants so if
the expectation
is that taxpayer money would not be used
to let's say
build a charter school
which is then dissolved a year later and
with with no dissolution no no agreement
with the with the department to to pay
those assets back uh to the state
left up to the department alone and then
and then the the disposition of those
assets is sold privately so now you've
seen um you know construction dollars
taxpayer dollars used to build a charter
that then dissolves a year later and the
um the whoever the head of the charter
is you know sells the building keeps the
cash so we've got to look out for for um
for the taxpayer to prevent things like
that from happening i mean those are
called loopholes in the law and we need
to make sure that that's even though
you're absolutely right that that
up and up wouldn't wouldn't do that but
we need to make sure that we don't have
loopholes in the law that enable that to
happen
mr chairman i feel like i'm getting a
little close to a debate here i just
yeah yeah we don't want to go there the
law
gives the department all tons of room to
actually
write an agreement such that the state
and the bond
holders can get paid back i don't
i understand it's the representative
does not think it's tight enough i'm
suggesting that there's
the procedure right there actually
allows the department and the state
board of education to
make sure people get paid back
thank you
yes represent tanner um
maybe it's because
i haven't i know you are like
deep into the building aid and grants um
and i haven't been
and
it this is really um
like too much uh
with too much confusion
um
around this
and that we need some uh balanced
experts to come in and talk talk about
this i think this really needs interim
study
uh so that
um at least
we can
you know get down into the weeds a
little bit because this is just getting
kind of almost too much today
further discussion
uh yes go ahead represent woodcock this
is a huge representative
just for clarification for me
the the 30 percent payback
for
public public schools
right now if it isn't if you're a public
let's say your district receives 30 of
what you're asking for right okay okay
so
the payback
will
the payback of the money if it dissolves
do i understand that correctly it's 30
no
if the pay you have to pay it all back
you have to pay everything you got back
okay under the okay so can i fall off
the other part i was trying to get
through because i was lost i'm coming
out of the weeds here so
under this going back to that z piece
that
seems to be confusing at least to me um
and it goes to the department where it's
not
it was going to be
the same as
the current
building aid law
that would be a hundred percent
right if it could be exactly the same as
a public school 100 percent i heard this
gentleman talking in
representative
munoz conversation that would be up to
the
doa to make that determine thank you
determination so does that mean that
they could be changed by
charter school so
one child school get fifty percent one
paid back forty percent or twenty
percent would that be since it's not set
and standard because the only standard
is public which is a hundred
now i'm a little bit lost on you on the
public getting a hundred percent they
don't get 100 they have to pay back 100
of their money right
on the grant
so under this under this
where we just said that the state board
is going to set it for under this but
chatter schools and he said they would
do that which is fine
my question is would that then be a
varying amount because on the public
school it's a hundred percent so but
that doesn't say that here for charter
schools the comments you made where the
doa would set it
from the solution plan
so my question is could that be a
variable amount
could be 40 for one child school 100 for
another
probably
i don't want to make a respond to that
because i really
i'm not quite understanding where you're
coming back with the hundred percent uh
they'd have to pay back the total grant
which they had received from the state
from that pot that from the 50 million
and i is this money coming from the 50
million
or is there a separate pot that's what i
was asking you
i i don't know
i don't know okay i have not i've never
discussed you know building aid for
charter schools prior to this okay and
it's all coming in pretty fast yeah okay
thank you
so so mr chair i do i do believe it
would be a varying amount between 30 and
60 percent because paragraph c on page
two of the bill is still in there even
if the bill were amended
uh with this so well if that part's in
there yes it would be but it'd be
varying based upon
the criteria
which we don't know
we know it for the public school system
that's
based upon those two criteria which been
mentioned here earlier
um but that was my point because i
didn't i couldn't understand that yeah
thank you i didn't think it was fair but
with the charter schools kids are coming
from all kinds of different
directions different districts etc and
it's uh
we can't use that same two variables
okay thank you
representative
yeah i think the intent in the amendment
was um to have a flat rate of 30 percent
uh but inadvertently um that section c
uh remains um and is not removed in the
amendment which complicates things
that would make a variable right glenn
because it's not in there okay that's my
whole question that that was the whole
point that was yeah okay thank you
appreciate your help
mr chairman just to add to
representative cordelia's point you
could clarify that by just striking that
that c-section and then it's it's 30
percent like it's supposed to be
so we're talking about another amendment
here
yeah yeah all this has to be done today
and we're starting to slide with a lot
of amendments and unfortunately
i don't know if we have the time to keep
doing this uh we're not making any
progress at all today and and in
addition mr chair i think there still is
that open question uh well it's not an
open question in the amendment roman 2a
on section 1
leaves it up to the department to
determine the disposition or
to determine in conjunction with the
charter with respect to the disposition
of assets
and and even if even if
paragraph c
were to remain as it's in statute right
now where the state grant is 30 of
eligible construction costs that would
likely mean that the charter is
somehow either combination of
fundraising or bonding
raising the the remaining 70 percent and
likely the um the first um
lien holder on the on the charter would
be the bond nut company and certainly
the state's not a lien holder in that
case certainly not in first position
so
so it really does raise the question of
how the state gets gets paid back even
if that were to be included an agreement
between the department and the uh the
charter because it's not in
we're not requiring apparently not being
required in this bill or the amendment
is there any rule making authority given
to the department to make the decision
on how to the criteria for setting up
the disposition and processes uh
i'm concerned that you know
that we could get a lot of inconsistency
here between these agreements or
disposition agreements between one
charter and another charter if in fact
we haven't taken that process through
rulemaking and back to jail car
to
establish a process that's going to be
consistent
mr chairman i don't know the answer on
the rule-making piece yeah yeah
well the thing is what we're dealing
with here we're dealing with a totally
new area
of law dealing with and i support
charter schools yes i do
but there are some fiscal questions here
and processes that you know are
explained in a couple sentences without
a lot of you know
uh in-depth understanding um
uh are they gonna have to jump on that
same list the 10-year projection list
which we just passed previously uh in in
the previous session uh are they on a
separate list
i you know none of that to me is really
clear i haven't had time to read at all
and that's that's part of my problem and
sort of your first one is that this just
gives them the ability to get on the
list of as all other public schools
there's not nothing there's not a
separate list
so at any rate we're going to need an
amendment here
or
or or move it to interim study
rick i mean
we've had tons of bills
and we can't yeah i i got that and we
have about five hours to get them all
done
so um what we'll do is we'll
break right now because it's time for
lunch time to really re regather
ourselves a little bit here we can have
a discussion during lunch
and and then come back and and pick this
one up at that time
so we're gonna break right now it's 12
o'clock
and we'll come back uh we're going to
take a 45 minute today not not an hour
cut it back to 45 minutes
so we can try to get this stuff done
thank you
um
[Music]
you
he knows i gave it to him
okay we're going to go ahead and start
we're waiting on some amendments on
bills which we haven't got back yet
and we're going to do 1367.
yes it is
yes that is yours represent cordelia
you're
recognized
for a motion
thank you mr
chair do you have your mic on
sorry thank you mr chairman um house
bill 1367
i would like to uh
uh move ought to pass
and there is an amendment
is there a second
second
okay uh reps and cordelli you're
recognized
uh
thank you um
in the hearing for this do you want to
introduce
the amendment well go ahead do the
offers uh there was a discussion uh
about this bill related to civics about
um
the uh
both the local
assessment and the uh u.s citizenship
test and the
amendment addresses those
concerns
so you want to introduce the amendment
thank you uh yes i'd like to move um
to pass on amendment
0 9 33
is there a second
second
thank you
would you like to speak to the amendment
uh thank you
um
basically
the amendment uh leaves in
the requirement from the original bill
that accommodations may be provided
for the examination
but it clarifies
that the results of just
the us citizenship
test would be sent to the part to the
department not both the local assessment
and
the civics test
since the local assessment
could vary between districts uh i'm not
sure of um the value to the department
so um it would just be the u.s
citizenship test that is results that
are sent to the department
further discussion representative
woodcut thank you um just a question
why do these why are these tests um i
wasn't here for the initial discussion
yesterday why do these tests need to be
submitted to the
deal anyhow what are the results
why do the results need to be submitted
thank you
uh they can
track that the assessments are being
done and also uh have an idea of
how our students are doing on the
civics test
go ahead this is the naturalization test
i i don't understand okay i hear what
you're saying but
the department wants to track how the
students are doing on a
test that's right off the computer
that they that they can just download
if were you asking a question
or you know discussion i was just trying
to ask that a question
well you don't have to ask a question
you can just discuss it i don't think we
could hear you all the way over here
okay
thank you you know i was surprised that
the the department had to or is
collecting this data when the the
information is downloaded from a
computer with a testing answers i don't
understand what the
i don't understand why why this would be
valuable for them to collect
and what do they think what are they
going to do if
school doesn't that
they've already said it's requirement of
graduation
so i just i don't i don't understand the
rationale for the collection that's all
further discussed represent luna
um thank you very much so um based on
what representative cordelli um has said
could um could we ask the department
since they're recording and tracking uh
how our students are doing on both the
currently under under law both the
locally developed competency assessment
um
uh of the united states government and
civics as well as the um the uscis could
we request a report from the department
on how our students are presently doing
on both these two tests can we get that
from them today
i have no idea whether they have that
i think i just saw attorney fenton
here
i don't think she's here
is she outside
on the horn she's she's in the hallway
now on the horn oh okay okay so um so
that's that's the first part i think i
i think it makes sense for for our
committee to at least be able to
baseline based on what representative
cordelli said that there's too much
variability in the locally developed one
but in fact um statue
says a locally developed competency
assessment of the united states
government and civics that includes but
is not limited to the nature purpose
structure function in history of the
united states government the rights and
responsibilities of citizens
and noteworthy government and civics
leaders shall be administered to
students as part of the required high
school course in history and government
of the united states and
of new hampshire
so that's in paragraph
um the paragraph that immediately
follows stopping right there at the end
of that sentence
when that was put in there there was no
intent
i can remember doing it that there's no
intent to forward that on they just had
to complete that at the local level to
determine if the you know it was a step
towards
graduation i don't you know i i don't
even know if it was that but it was
never intended to go to the department
that one was not i think what we have
here on this immunization
immunization
immigration test on citizenship uh that
it's
it's a
the makers are trying to get that
aggregate
data from the department as to
where our kids are functioning in regard
to that test
right but oh and and i see attorney
fenton has
has
is here could we ask her if um if we can
get that information
reps on fenton uh
uh-oh
i don't know if you're down to captain
or up the governor i don't know but
representative ladd well you should see
how many bills we ended up in recess so
representative ladd
i have a question
no no no no no no we
what is the question so so the the
the question
is uh based on what representative
cordelli said that the um that the
department currently records and tracks
student performance
on both the locally developed competency
assessment for united states government
and civics
and the the u.s citizenship and
immigration services test was wondering
if we could get a um a present report a
current report from the department on
how students across the state are doing
on both those
tests
can that even happen today
i will do my best because that would
happen today i understand where we are
procedurally in the hearing and yes i
will make some calls and see if i can
i'm not sure that we're even this bill
has even been implemented yet um so
on the civic uh citizenship test
we've had the other portion in law for a
number of years
uh i have a question then representative
porter um
where where the local test is an
assessment that's designed locally
you must then have like the you do with
your inputs as far as you know and you
have
testing which you got the information on
but the inputs are basically a narrative
report to the department on adequacy
is that similar to what we have here
with this locally designed that there's
a narrative report given or
or do you get their actual assessment
itself and
and look at the
that data
i'm not sure and for the record diana
fenton an attorney with the department
of education um
i'm not sure if we get it in a narrative
form but the issue you have identified
is one that the department has
identified that
we get variations
of these reports in and so there is no
you know it's it's hard to have a
standard to compare them to if they're
all if they're locally designed so i
will let you know if it is a narrative
thank you representative porter
thank you
i don't know if this is necessary you
gotta bring the mic down
hello yeah
testing
i don't know if this is a question for
you attorney fentanyl for the group um
i'm looking up uh rsa 189 11 and it
pertains to both public and private
schools do the provisions of this bill
also
pertain to both public and private
schools
in other words are we requiring private
schools to give
the citizenship test now
and if so
how does that fit in with the plans
so i i do not
have my law book in front of me um which
is a rarity
we gave you a free copy
i know i actually don't tell anyone but
i have two free copies
i know
this isn't being recorded is it
um
that's right
i'm glad people thought that was
humorous
oh gosh i was gonna do what i do and
write in your book i apologize
um if i might mr chairman um uh 189
11 that we're talking about i believe it
takes effect
uh july 1 2023
the way it was originally
put together though
you could develop a locally designed
assessment test
and if you pass that into school you are
awarded a certificate
it didn't necessarily say graduation and
said you could get a certificate for
completing this successfully that's i
think as far as we had taken it when we
first did this
and there was also the option that if
you didn't do that you could use the
other
federal test
can i ask a question while diana sure
yes
would there be a cost to the local
school district for doing this
we discussed that when we passed initial
doing your local assessment there's no
cost to it other than what you normally
do
at that time all those materials were
available free
online so where there's no cost for
purchasing that that uh immigration test
i meant now the district you have to
gather that information and send it up
to the to the state well you're going to
have secretarial staff or administrative
staff you're going to have to compile
the results if that's what you're doing
what you should be doing
so it takes time
so
so there is a cost to the local district
for doing this
time is money kind of an unfunded
mandate huh yeah i'm funded mandate
go ahead did you have did you were you
waiting for us uh diane um well i i have
an answer to representative porter's
question
um thankfully um
due to representative tanner's
initiative uh there was a book that i
could review so
um
so when i look at and again this is
always my disclaimer one attorney's
opinion you asked
two attorneys and you'll get five
different opinions
so
when you look at 189 colon 11. your
question was it begins by saying in all
public and private schools so then is
the assessment equally applicable to
private schools that's your question
correct all right so when i look at this
i think a reasonable interpretation
based on the rules of statutory
construction
when you look at paragraph one it is
all-encompassing public and private
schools when you look at paragraph two
and you'll see on page 448 in the yellow
book paragraph two effective until july
1st 2023 see also paragraph two below
right that's recognizing the old
language of the law and then the new
language that will come into effect but
paragraph two in either version starts
out saying as a component of instruction
under paragraph one
so i would read it to be inclusive of
the language in paragraph one applicable
to public and private schools but again
i go back to my disclaimer
one lawyer's opinion
and that's that's all this is but i
think that's a reasonable interpretation
based on statutory construction
question represent cordelia uh yes i i
don't think that
whether this applies to public or
private schools
or both
is any part of this bill or the
amendment
right and it and if i could answer the
other question about
time to do it
this is already in law effective july 1
so
all we are doing is in this amendment is
providing accommodations for students
and saying that not both
test results have to be sent to the
department just this u s citizenship
test results
and i believe that that amendment was
suggested on behalf of the department of
education and and i apologize because i
was out in the hall my boss was calling
me but i i think that that was part of a
discussion that the department brought
forward um based on some current
concerns of the bill that was passed
previously
so this was to to clarify some issues
further discussion represented woodcock
thank you attorney thank you tell me
what the department does
with the data that's going to come from
from specifically just this one test
that's
computerized online and the answers are
there what valid validity would we send
that in
um
i think there's really two parts to your
question what does the department do
with it
we collect it we will maintain it it
will be available for inspection your
other question the validity of it is
more of a policy question
and
that is more of a attorney answer
committee answer
right the department does not make those
policy decisions thank you troy thank
you
represent mullin
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question attorney so as a
component of instruction under paragraph
one public and private the last
statement in this amendment says by june
30th of each year each school district
shall submit the results
to the doe
would that um would this compel private
schools to also
send results to the doe
no
no i think school district has yeah
i mean i i think that there is a
terminology
i don't want to say words are important
because i think that's uh i don't want
to step into your shoes but terminology
and consistency of terminology is
something that we at the department are
always working on
if you look at our rules we struggle
with that and we have really tried to
take the initiative to to address that
terminology issue and i think we see
that throughout the statutes and
certainly in our rules and in in our own
vocabulary i i find myself having to do
that as well so certainly something to
be aware of
represent tanner
thank you um i'm struggling with the
intent of this bill as i think some of
the other questions that you've heard
from the committee kind of go around why
all of a sudden does the state
department decide that they need
to
have school districts provide this
information and you remarked that
there were some concerns
so maybe if you could talk about some of
the concerns maybe the intent would be a
little bit more clear to me
so thank you for the question
um
the concerns are not about
the policy
initiatives the concerns are about this
bill was passed last session
and when the department goes to
implement
the law
um those are that's when the concerns
arise
um those are when those
discrepancies are discovered
because you can you can write a bill you
can write a law and then when you
implement it and really test it that's
when you'll find those inherent
discrepancies and i think that is what
nate greene testified to is that in
implementing the law there were just
some issues and we felt as a department
that
there could be some corrections made to
in order to implement but the department
doesn't bring those forward
to correct policy
that is done by this committee so if
that helps to
clarify that
yes
so
i think it made a little bit less clear
to me what the intent is or what the
concerns are
because it's a requirement for
graduation
uh this test
and
so the requirements for graduation
are approved by the local school board
at the local level
that they they're the ones that
certified whether a student actually
meets all those requirements
for graduation so
is this like a
gotcha for local school districts or is
it a way to
indicate and as uh representative
woodcock said you know all the answers
are online so
actually it should be 100
um you know
responses from from kids if they can
just go online and find all the answers
anyway
so
i
i'm still confused about
what are the concerns in the intent with
the
implementation of the
are you feeling like not all schools are
doing it um
you know what exactly is it i don't
understand
oh well in my apologies i don't have the
current amendment in front of me um what
i can tell you in broad terms
this was um again when the department
went to implement this bill which was
passed last session is my understanding
there were some concerns in
the implementation of it and we
identified some areas as i think it
pertained to special ed i know there's
some language in there about that and
just in terms of how it's going to be
applied throughout the state
uh
equally to all school districts it was
never intended to be a gotcha but this
was in order to implement this and in
order to effectuate the purpose of this
law
we identified we as a department
identified some areas that we felt
needed some clarity and that's what the
intent of that was bringing it forward
it
was to rectify some issues that we saw
with a bill that had been previously
passed um and
we've done that
with in other areas with other bills
representative
thank you um if we could get back maybe
to
the bill
and the amendment
this is in current statute
um you know on page 448 in your book
this is all in current statute
the original bill does two things
it puts in the accommodations as um
attorney fenton just mentioned terms of
special needs children
and it said that both the local
assessment and the us test had to be
submitted to the department
it's already in law that
orr
is in law now
the original bill says both
the amendment based on the hearing
says
not both
not or
just the us citizenship test has to be
sent to the department those are the
only two things the bill and the
amendment does it has
nothing to do with whether it's public
or private schools
it has nothing to do with
the
the test itself or number of questions
or the scores or anything else none of
that is in this bill
if i
may i think that
that language was recommended because
the department identified
the difficulty of the the local
assessment going back to representative
lad's original comment
that
there was a lack of consistency in what
the department could report out on if
there are all these local locally
developed assessments and i know that
was part of the discussion as we um
crafted this back in the fall
and then there was also the concern
about
providing the accommodations
uh so
we the department viewed this as a
cleanup bill to address some concerns
and implementation of the law that was
previously passed and that was that was
the only
reason behind it thank you
further yes representative ellison thank
you thank you mr chairman uh
representative cordelli uh looking at
the amendment uh lines 15 well line 14
and 15
each school district shall submit is it
your understanding that includes private
schools or not
it has nothing to do with my
interpretation um the attorney has
talked about her interpretation of the
law
the intent with the amendment was to
address only
that
justice
that's the only thing that i addressed
in the amendment based on testimony in
the public hearing on the bill
follow up
and i'll address this to attorney fenton
uh line 15 each school district shall
submit the results in your reading that
includes private schools or not no no
no that's very similar to representative
mullen's question thank you
represent luno
thank you very much mr chair just a
follow-up on on
um what representative ellison was
talking about and representative mullen
was talking about
and and how the the terms
public and private schools are used
the term high schools
is used and the term public i'm sorry a
school district
is also used all within paragraph one
and and
uh i guess i'm wondering as as um as you
read paragraph one
do do the do the use of of these various
terms refer to the same things or or
different things
um or is it or or is that or is this
basically a fielder's choice use of um
use of terms to um to essentially refer
to schools
i mean i'm wondering i'm wondering about
the legislative intent whether it was
deliberate to uh to somehow see a break
there given the fact that that so many
different terms that refer to the same
thing are being used in paragraph one
and i think this is relevant to the
amendment and to the bill because it uh
it certainly relates to the scope of um
of applicability but you're trying to
ask us if it's our the department
whether
what you're asking for is relevant what
you're asking for has no relationship
with the amendment
it does by the virtue of the scope
because if it turns out that that these
are terms that all refer to the same
thing then that would that would
certainly flow down through into
paragraph two as it does
intentionally in the top of paragraph
two as a component of instruction under
paragraph one
and and what the amendment and what the
underlying bill do is modify some words
um
in paragraph two so i think the scope is
absolutely relevant to knowing what
we're getting into here
mr chairman the scope is not
um altered in any way
um by the uh
by the amendment or by the main bill
um you know i
you know i i'm not going to repeat
myself for the fourth time but you know
it's 1 30.
under school improvement and assessment
it mentions district and that's relevant
to the school districts which are public
school districts in our state has
nothing to do with private schools when
it comes to improvement and assessment
that's not our game to go in and assess
those private schools unless they want
to be an approved school and they've
come to the department and asked for
that approval so at this point in time i
think it's time to call this question we
have a lot to do today and we're going
to be here to seven o'clock eight
o'clock if we have to to get this done
we cannot meet tomorrow it's not posted
for tomorrow we can't continue this to
tomorrow it's got to be done today
so
i'd like to move forward here
thank you very much for miss fenton
okay so we have a motion on that
on the table we have an amendment that's
been proposed that's hp 1360 excuse me
213.67 it's amendment 0933h
and let's see we've already
yeah we have to vote on that amendment
so it's uh
up to you uh mr clerk
you can do a show of hands if you if you
care
okay
all those in favor of the amendment show
your hands please
those opposed
okay
you get women we to count them you know
because we can't see around the corner
so well here
four five six seven
okay how many did you get
on that are opposed seven okay put your
hands up if you're four again and have
the clerk count those again
one two three
nine ten
eleven twelve okay thank you
okay we have the amendment approved now
it's we need a motion to approve the
the bill as amended
so
mr chairman
and second by representing hobson motion
to approve 1367 as amended
further discussion
represent representative nelson would
you please
representative cordelli yes represent
litchfield
um i'm sorry nodder excuse me two
representative johnson
yes representatives yes
representative uh
first yes yes all right thank you
hopson representative yes representative
ford
yes representative soda yes
representative nelson yes representative
luno
no
representative cornell
oh representative jack
uh no
sorry about that representative tanner
no
representative ellison
representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter no i'm a
representative hall no
right and representative yeah
representative ladd oh forgot you too
okay
robert shaw did that all the time that's
ten to nine ten to nine
so dave who's going to be doing the
amendment uh who wants to do the
minority
uh not the amendment the minority
request
be itl yep yep okay thank you
okay we got some amendments up here
where we got here
let's go to 1434.
fourteen
we passed this out i believe right so
there's one right here so
we may need one more one
okay no i took mine so maybe uh
do you have
0 9
do you have that
no it was it just came downstairs
get some extras
this was moved to a different area we
spoke about
okay did we have any kind of emotion on
the table i just wanted to no we didn't
tell us
i don't think so no we didn't
okay thank you um so okay go ahead i'll
give the gavel to you
thank you this is house bill 1453
relative
1434.
thank you
turn the page
uh house bill 1434 relative to the
availability of school curriculum
materials and uh
call on the chairman ladd for a motion
thank you very much uh i move out to
pass on 1434.
i have a second
representative hobson thank you
um comment from uh chairmanland yes i'd
like to further
move
uh zero nine nine two h an amendment two
14 34.
second
representative hobson again thank you
okay i'd like to speak to the amendment
seeing that the amendment is the is the
bill now everything else you see as it
was introduced is not there
first of all this has changed the
uh location
within law that we've been addressing
uh to 186 colon 11 roman 9
c
and this is an area within law which we
have which deals with the sentence
currently says to the extent practicable
a school district shall make curriculum
materials available to parents or legal
guardians for review upon request
and we're talking in this about
curriculum course materials used for
instruction
and so this amendment goes to read now
to the extent practicable
and upon request from a parent legal
guardian or resident of the public
school district to review curriculum
course material used to support student
learning in a grade level course or
program at a school operated and
governed in its district the district
shall make available the requested
curriculum course material within 10
business days
it's a response to parents who are
asking to see curriculum course
materials
and to the in in the past it's been to
the extent practical and of course
you might have a whole boatload of
materials which you cannot duplicate you
can't replicate and and you're gonna
have to make arrangements to have that
done however for many things which
curriculum is written down that you have
a 10 days to get it together and and or
have it available so a parent can come
in and look at it
thank you representative hopson any
comments
anything further from the committee uh
representative porter
thank you mr chair is that 10 days from
the date of the request or 10 days from
the date the material was used
business days are the day those are
business days so it'd be your
from from the request yes and then it's
business days saturday and sunday
excluded
something that i use in my classroom on
monday
i have 10 i would not have to give up 10
days from monday
to be shown to the parent is it
is it days you have 10 days to get it
together you don't have to show it
within those that those days but it's
something that i used two weeks ago
i would need to have available if it's a
worksheet i made up for example or that
sort of thing i would need to keep it so
that it could be available two weeks
later for a parent to see
if a parent comes in and says i want to
see your social study materials that
you're using in your classroom that
could be any time
and it doesn't have it's it's upon the
moment they're requesting so from that
point forward
first of all i as a teacher would sit
down with that parent say or that
request or it could be a legal guardian
or whatever it says in here
uh resident of the district it's not
just any anybody that can come in and
ask for this stuff they sit down talk
about it and then uh
facilitate what that parent's asking for
in in conformance with this right here
which is your curriculum course
materials which those are already in law
and where
practicable
any further questions uh scene none um
i'm sorry
we had um
a person come in who was very disturbed
that um
or
i i can't remember if the person was or
had heard this
that somebody was actually getting a
call from the local police about a
desist order
for constantly approaching a school
district
for curriculum materials course
materials and i'm wondering if
if there's a cap on this or if it's only
for
like you said it can't be just somebody
coming in it had to be somebody in the
school district or a parent or
does it have to be a parent of a child
in the school
and
can it just refer to the
the parents
child's curriculum
oh is there any kind of i i would just
say that uh on line 16 it says the
parent legal guardian or resident of the
district
um i don't know if representative vlad
has any further
comment on that well we we we had taken
in account that and i think in some of
our previous
amendments which we've had it was wide
open this is specific to
and this is not an uncommon thing which
occurs you know you
i would encourage parents to come in and
and ask what are we doing um
wonderful way to do the homework and
help out at home
so i
i think that this is
in alignment with what we have been
doing i don't see anything only what
this does is basically it puts in a
place that it's going to be done within
10 days after you you've had that
contact from the individual requesting
it
can i have a follow-up to that
so i i i just um you know from what we
heard there were people within the
school district that were coming in and
asking for curriculum course materials
uh
who were not had did really didn't have
a vested interest to do that i mean i
can see parents having a vested interest
coming in and and as you said you know
in the 35 years i taught i talked to
many parents and
you know set out course materials for
that too but
um
i'm just kind of concerned that
you know i don't want to open
open this up to okay it has to be you
know show us all your curriculum
materials because i live in the district
and um you know
whatever they want to do with it so i i
think that in response that there
this says they uh make available the
reques excuse me the district shall make
available it doesn't say the teacher the
district's going to have to develop a
policy in how to implement this
they may want you to come in first and
talk maybe to the teacher or maybe the
prince building principle
and the district may have these
materials at a location somewhere
somewhere in the district which they
come yeah we got that available in the
media center come on in you're welcome
to look at it but it's available to
anybody in that district a resident of
that public school district
and there are taxpayers that would like
to see times what what is in the school
and being used for curriculum materials
that's i think that's a right to access
that material
represent luna
thank you very much mr chair um just a
question that sort of bridges over from
what representative porter was asking
and what representative tanner was
asking but let's say that in
representative porter's classroom
she um
she does a couple of things
she um she has her students watch a um
uh a 20 or a a
a um i don't know a five-minute segment
on uh on cnn uh with regards to ukraine
and then um and then uh hands out a um
a worksheet that that she's developed um
what
of of of at least those two materials
what would need to be
presented
for review
within 10 business days following a
request well we do have within 8306
definition of resources and materials we
do have within statutory law definition
of curriculum
certainly if you're
teaching
current events in a upper elementary
class intermediate school four through
six
and the old weekly reader you used to
get in the mail numerous copies i know
bill just left but he probably did it
too i did it
and the weekly reader's little newspaper
that comes out and has current events in
it that you know i would say that weekly
reader is you know my um
part of my curriculum materials i don't
need to have every copy of weekly reader
available uh that would certainly make
it just
that's not practical
so i think we have some discretion here
thank you that's that's sort of what
what i was looking for is that that term
practicable which
any further yes representative porter
thank you mr chair and
i guess i'm just really concerned about
the language in this bill that says
anybody who lives in a school district
can ask for these materials
and i love the people in my district
but sometimes
there are unusual characters in the town
and i can see that perhaps they would
want to
investigate and they have no children in
the school they have no
you know they're not worried about
what's being said in the classroom but
they know there's a topic out there
that's hot and they maybe want to catch
somebody doing it um and that they could
just walk in and demand this material um
i'm i'm no i'm hearing and i'm seeing
from
colleagues who are in the classroom now
a real fear
and a real concern
many of them are talking about leaving
the professional together because of the
stresses that they're under
we've passed bills that
they're not sure what they can say in
class and
they're not sure what they can teach and
what books they can give
they're not sure about a lot of things
and now to know that anybody
could question what they're doing by
coming in and saying i demand to see
what mary smith is doing in her
classroom because i think i've heard
something bad about her that scares me
it scares me for them and for their
safety so i'm i'm really concerned about
that particular language
it's not in the original statute i don't
think
the original statute said parents or
guardians
now we have
someone new to the district that just
moved well we have residents in there
now and i as a grandparent i'm not a
legal guardian i'm not a parent i'm the
grandparent
i'd like to access that materials also
we have various schools that are
supporting the school district within
our district that would love to be able
to dovetail and line what they're doing
with the schools
i i think there's going to be a lot of
discretion here
not discretion but responsibility placed
on the administrators within the
building the principles they're there
for a purpose
and
i don't think this says that you're
going to want anybody's going to walk
into a classroom i wouldn't allow it
this is just a request of the school
district to provide the curriculum
materials they can be provided and it
doesn't even have to be the teacher
that's but i i in the situation where it
is the parent or the uh legal guardian i
think it'd be a wonderful opportunity
for the teacher and those people to work
together
thank you um any further comments
representative luno sure but i think
that's a that's a very good good
question as to why why i mean i
i understand it in representative ladd's
case that as as um as a parent or legal
guardian or somebody who's who clearly
has a responsibility for um
for for for a child who's being educated
in the public school district living in
their home that they should be able to
to go in
and
and and
request
to the extent practicable
to review curriculum and course material
but now i'm reading this as as any
resident of the public school district
which i think is representative porter's
concern and and those
residents of the public school district
yes their tax dollars are paying for the
public education there but their access
to information is through their local
school board through their local elected
officials and not directly through the
uh through the school district and so
i'm i'm i'm wondering what this really
does in terms of it's and it's not
it's not exposing the school district to
to something that they're trying to
um
it's it's it's it's it's it's just
potentially putting uh putting a an
unreasonable burden on
on the um the the sau or the central
office where where where you know
residents i mean i certainly understand
it parent legal guardian or somebody
that's that's responsible for a child um
student
would uh would would be interested to
know what their what the materials are
um but uh but for uh for uh for a
resident you know your channel is
through the is through the local elected
school board
and um and so i'm not i'm
is there a better term
here mr chair the
representative ladd that would
that would
um
i guess support what you were saying you
know that that all right i'm taking care
of a student in my household and i'm not
a parent or a legal guardian but i
definitely want to have access to these
materials
we have a school board which is the
governing body they're the governance of
the school district the administration
superintendent principal supervisors
curriculum directors are there to
administer
the the instruction the curriculum
and when we're saying that a person that
lives in that community cannot have
access to information about that school
you must go to school board
i think we're really starting to
um
draw sides uh in education here and i i
think we're going down a wrong path here
i think it's time that we work together
cooperatively the taxpayer in that town
is paying for all those materials in
those classrooms and i think they have
the right to know
what's being taught uh in schools uh and
and materials being used uh it's
it's you know to me that's just
uh common
working for the common good of children
and and that's the bottom reason why
we're all here is for the child and if
we're going to not allow a resident
district which is looking trying to
become more knowledgeable and
understanding the schools and possibly
even trying to help the schools
um why are you going to say well you've
got to go jump through all these hoops
to get access to that that just is going
to scare parents away and put up a
barrier and say look they're trying to
hide something from us
no i'm talking about the residents of
the district
i think it's time to
call it
uh one comment does it bother you that
there is now groups that have bounties
out there uh payments
for uh finding
uh different things that are presented
in curriculum materials that they might
consider
i'm not sure that that bears on uh this
amendment that we're discussing
any further representative porter
i'm sorry but i think it does bear do
you know that there are more than 35
teachers who have been
turned in for investigation this in this
last few months
35 teachers have been questioned
already
the environment that we are in right now
is very different than the environment
we were used to when we were growing up
in the communities in the schools
it's scary out there
people are scared i'm sorry
representative you don't like that i'm
saying this but people are scared
they're afraid of people other people
even their friends they don't know
and people are
can come and say and do things
that are frightening
there is going it's a scary time for
schools you heard what mr christina said
about the exhaustion and the stress that
schools have been under that teachers
have been under that staff and faculty
and administrations have been under and
always making it sound like the school
is the enemy
and that the public has a right
against the schools which is how this
comes out we want to know what's going
on in these schools because we don't
trust them
well and that's what's coming out to the
schools
and when we put this kind of language in
i'm afraid of hostile actors what
happened to the school board member in
derry
you read that article this is scary
stuff and instead of soothing it it's
making it worse when we do these that's
what i'm concerned about all of the
curriculum material is available to
parents already just community members
it's all online in most school districts
and
saying that it's not
doesn't
and saying that you need to protect
it just i'm sorry i'm really
concerned about this as you can tell
if if the curriculum materials are
already available then there should be
no problem with passing this
so are there any further comments yeah
it doesn't say in here that you have to
do it first and first you can put this
stuff online just as well just like you
know like represent cordelia said
um
if we're going to start hiding all this
stuff i i i fear we're
hiding
no we're not it's there already
well then if it's available then there
shouldn't be an issue
well why do we even have to have this
bill
just to be sure because we don't trust
the schools that they're doing it
in in some places it is not readily
available
can we
proceed with a call uh or show of hands
um on the amendment please
uh all those in favor of the amendment
okay thank you and opposed
10-9 is that
i'm sorry
do we have the no votes again please
some question on the no votes could they
raise your hand if you don't mind
it's nine okay thank you yeah
okay
um an emotion on yes
as amended with
h ought to pass as amended
second
represent no i'd prefer someone other
than a sub
uh representative hopson
ready for a vote
thank you uh mr clerk
thank you
representative um cordelli
yes representative nutter yes
representative johnson yes
representative lucas yes representative
burns
yes
representative hopson yes
representative ford yes representative
soda yes representative nelson yes
representative
luno
no
representative
uh
marybeth
jack excuse me uh no okay cornell
representative
cornell
no okay
representative tanner no representative
ellison no
representative mullen no representative
woodcock
representative porter no representative
hall no
representative land yes
ten to nine
okay
i assume that was made by lad that
motion yes it was
okay we got
we got the uh mr chair school building
yes i asked for five minute recess
please sure go ahead
we're going to take a five minute recess
here
mr chairman thank you so much for the
recess i thought you were going to go
down and get some soda for us
after your help
you know in alaska they don't call it
soda they call it pop yeah
i think that must be a western it's
tonic in massachusetts tonic
yeah that is
okay is everybody back
okay great
everybody's thrilled to be here
okay keep marching everybody's doing a
good job here
we have some very difficult
bills coming up and
when we all walk out of reps hall and
you know i've done it now for 14 years
and there's sometimes there's not
sometimes we've often had you know
issues which we've not seen things eye
to eye
but the next day i'm out good friends
with folks and we're we're having fun
together so it's just this is all what
our country is all about it's a
democratic uh society and
let's just keep that in mind because i
don't think anything's done
anything's done here you know
to to hurt or anything such that let's
let's just
stay
up on the high road be magnanimous
and
know that
this is all about kids
rick i i i would echo what you what you
say now but i think politics has changed
in the last few years and i and i think
one of the one of the things that that
has always worked out well in new
hampshire is that we work together to
compromise on things and the the number
of bills going 10-9 not only in this
committee but in committees throughout
the new hampshire house
i i think is it really really speaks to
the to the sickness that we have in new
hampshire politics and and i hope we can
get back
to to a time where where we've worked
things out and um
and you know it seems like out of this
committee uh we're either all in
agreement
on something that's really simple to do
or we're going down party lines what i
think we're about to do here on 1671
um
uh
obviously it's been a very
tricky road with 1671 certainly given
where it started but but there has been
collaboration on um on on getting to
this one and hopefully we can see more
uh work like this rather than rather
than extreme party line stuff that that
you know is not going to have the
durability that i think granite staters
expect in the in the laws that we pass i
would concur with you uh but i think we
need to highlight
those
really important issues which we're
dealing with here we've dealt with
career technical education and know how
we came out on that bill uh
recognizing how we're going to align and
get scheduling for the kids between the
centers and the ascending schools uh
look at what we've done in terms of the
universities in terms of trying to
even with that subcommittee we had when
the governor was proposing merger and
how he worked there and represented
mullins how we worked on that committee
dealing with special education and
and and trying to
just weave through sometimes we're
weaving through minefields
and and um it's not easy but there are
some topics which are you know
near and dear to us all
that we do are successful at but there's
others which we're getting that national
agenda pouring down on us
and i i agree it's been very difficult
new hampshire's always been a little bit
above that then let's try to get back if
we're not there let's get back to it
and and let's move ahead so we do have
1671 in front of us right now
that was just passed out we have
i don't know how many bills left it must
be hopefully in the single digits now
so uh i got turned to the page of 1671.
yeah why don't you take the gavel on
this one please
uh thank you mr chairman uh this is
house bill 16
relative to the content of an adequate
education
and uh
call on
chairman ladd for a motion i would move
uh otp on 1671.
second
nelson great thank you
um
comment uh further chairman yes i'd like
to uh also move amendment
i think i've got the right one here
1024h
for 1671
we've gone through about four or five of
them yep
um
second by uh representative nelson again
sure and
comment uh further uh on the amendment
uh chairman i'd like to go ahead and
discuss uh the like the intent where why
this bill
uh as it is right now
um as it was introduced it was a bill
which was kind of a a hold over in many
parts and even had been developed
further than hb 242.
it tried to accomplish a lot very
quickly
and
there was some phraseology in it which i
will agree where
we had core
subjects or areas of learning and then
we had other areas which went above and
beyond that
at the bottom part of the sheet and
there is confusion is this now stating
that those are all the responsibility of
the local and not that of the state as
far as adequacy the content that's
required and of course then the all the
fray occurred dealing with
okay are we trying to unload some of the
financial burden to
uh local school districts
that is the responsibility of the of the
of the state and now as we look at the
legislature our judicial decisions that
came out of the claremont decision in
the latter part of the 90s
it was declared in those in those
readings that
the responsibility of the state to
deliver the opportunity for an adequate
education goes well beyond just reading
writing and arithmetic
it had to do with all those subjects and
i could read that
that
decision right here i have it in front
of me but the point is that it is more
than just that the knowledge and skills
that we need for working and living
together in this society so what this
this new amendment does
it takes the exact same language that we
had on lines five through seven on the
first page there that's right out of the
statutes right now with the exception
of line five that says and for each year
thereafter so this started back in 2008
and
went on the specific criterion
substantive educational program blah
blah blah
so now it's it's each year thereafter
and it spells out down below in these
learning areas now there's been a lot of
questions are how do we define
what is learning areas
when i met with attorneys today early
this morning at eight o'clock
the attorney said to me you could call
this anything you could call spaghetti
you're the legislature you have the
responsibility you can do that
and and but it what we are looking at is
we're looking at basically that
curriculum area or that subjects but
it's basically better called learning
areas
and i'll tell you that why as we whittle
down through this
the learning areas number one that you
have in this bill
are english language arts and reading
that's in law
everything down that points in law
mathematics that's in law science is in
law and science has left science because
then you can split that up into the
biological sciences the chemical
sciences and natural sciences the
physical sciences and on you go
that may be better done through the bill
we dealt with the other day when we talk
about studies
because within these
i'm not going to call subject areas but
in these learning areas you have various
studies which support that for example
we know that there's a number of topics
within physical education which we have
put into studies
and there's a number of areas which we
put into that same section law dealing
with nutrition
and history and instruction and all that
so going down to the social studies and
we've had discussion on it including
government economics geography history
in the holocaust and genocide
education
that's also in 193
e
that's pre in a section of law preceding
this i was also told today that what you
a person could make a real good case for
those materials which are underneath
knowledge and skills that precede this
section of law are part of adequacy
this is all in that adequacy chapter of
law
so going on down arts education
it says arts education and current law
what we've done is after representative
hall mentioned this the other day then i
went and started saying
yes that's i'm familiar with that and
that's what i've seen elsewhere
and so i picked up our our our rules
here and
and we gotta be careful we never develop
our statutes based on rules statutes are
rules are based on statute not statute
on rules
and we used to have at one point in time
after every one of these subjects the
reference to that section of ed 306 that
was all taken out simply because ed 306
can change any time but by the by the
state board they can't change our
statute
that's law that we have to do
and so under arts education it now
reflects what was in in uh
in in is in 306 and i'm going to read it
to you
it says arch arts education be provided
for each k through 12 student in music
and visual arts while developing
supplemental but not required
opportunities in dance media arts and
theater
so you can see there's three
supplemental areas but the required
areas
are the music and the visual arts that's
now in our law if we pass this and that
will so state to when we are looking
down the road at funding this this is
there this is part of an adequate
education this is part of that content
going on down to world languages that's
somewhere what we had health and
wellness health and wellness wellness
has never been there but health and well
wellness is all through 306 and we've
just done that in the area of studies as
well
um
what we in years to come we need to
address this one area here including a
policy for violations of rsa 126 k colon
roman 1 8.
that's an area that needs to be put in
the law it's in law right now right
there
but somewhere along the way it needs to
be taken out of this section of adequacy
and put elsewhere in statute it's it's
been placed incorrectly and that's
something we've i've been told over and
over by legislative services but that's
another day
that's nothing critical at this point in
time physical education
engineering and technologies including
technology applications the including
technology applications is new to this
bill new but it's also
a very vital part in in dealing with
engineering and technology
learning areas it's how you apply it and
use it
personal finance literacy that is a new
area and of course you know that that's
a result of the
the absolute support we've had come in
from the new hampshire bankers
association the chamber of commerce
business industry association
and we've had it come into through our
legislature in many years we've heard
people introduce bills on this
and it's also reflected in 306 right now
within economics at the high school it
also includes
personal finance there however that's
not the only place we should be teaching
this you don't wait until you take that
course in high school to teach a family
about family budget or a child that you
can't go into school in store and just
want this want that and and not equating
it to need versus want
uh then it goes on this uh area right
here teachers shall use academic and
applied instruction to teach the
learning areas and notice that it's no
longer core areas it's learning areas
they're of course out of this thing
totally
under sub paragraph a above and and then
we use and it used to be computer
science we had some discussion on it's
computer use it's a tool because the the
if you go up to technology applications
that's where you're where are
taking in account the new technologies
and it's just not all computers as well
there's others if you walk in career
technical education and you're going to
see all kinds of technology
and in the classrooms digital literacy
is extremely important
we need to integrate these type of
things along with logic and rhetoric
into the our instruction
for all these learning areas 1 through
10.
going down below
abc
are already in law that's those are
areas which deal with the net of the
standards
and definition of curriculum i won't go
into that that's in-law but these areas
right here are areas that you've seen
many times before that are in this and
the last part
is a part that deals with accountability
for an opportunity for inadequate
education and there's a lot of ways we
look for a there's two ways with the
inputs and the outputs there are the
performance side with the assessment
but the areas where we're looking into
in our state standards here in the
school
approval standards are these
10 areas that we had in the learning
areas along with those two other areas
which are in law currently regarding
the
minimum credit uh school year
requirements and minimum credits
required for high school diploma
the personal finance literacy
by putting it here as we did before it
also states that we give a year for
school districts to figure out how they
might want to embed it or integrate it
into areas of instruction
i would venture to say that many of our
elementary intermediate middle schools
are doing it right now and high schools
as well
we have certainly a lot of cooperation
from um various organizations to put
to do that so that's this bill that's
totally them it this replaces everything
else so we're not dealing with costing
we're not dealing with delivery we're
not dealing with some of the aspects the
other bills have done
so thank you very much mr chair uh
representative nelson is the secretary
do you have anything further no no
any further comments from the committee
uh representative luno sure thank you
very much mr chair and um and my um um
my assumption here uh representative
ladd is that this sets the floor
for um for
uh delivering an opportunity for an
adequate education and not the um and
not the ceiling for what a uh for what a
public school
may teach so if a public school did want
to teach computer science uh it could
certainly do that or teach um things
that are that are significantly extended
off of this
list isn't that correct that's
absolutely correct you know the local
school has responsibility for curriculum
and instruction uh this right here we're
identifying for the floor for our
opportunity for an adequate education we
are defining now those learning areas
that are
that are a must
and that we have to then look at that in
terms of when we're creating a funding
formula we're taking account these are
going to be
costs which the state has to absorb
anyone else
i'd like to make another call i'd like
to make a comment yes so so thank you
very much mr chair um
for uh um
for a lot of the same reasons
that um that i articulated yesterday i i
i don't believe
uh i am going to support the amendment i
am going to support the bill as amended
but for a lot of reasons i don't believe
now is a great time for um
for uh for the legislature to be um
monkeying around
the um representative ladd was in a
conversation anyway so i'll start from
well no i'll quickly so so
very very quickly i am going to support
the amendment i am going to support the
the bill is amended um but for a lot of
the same reasons i taught i i discussed
yesterday i don't believe now is a
really great time for um for the
legislature to be monkeying around
in um
in this neck of the woods uh there is a
uh obviously an ongoing lawsuit where
the state is uh
is a defendant and and this area is is
material to that i do believe the
amendment makes some make some very good
improvements in the areas of in the area
of of the um the approval standards um
for learning areas for uh for inadequate
education uh particularly the holocaust
and genocide education consistent with
with with what was enacted last year and
um and improvements with in in personal
finance literacy and some other um and
some other areas that were done so so i
think there's there's a lot here that um
that that is important but but i i am
concerned uh about the uh the timing and
whether this is um is is really good to
do at this point i hope the um
uh the other chamber will uh we'll
consider that as as as
you know in terms of whether or not um
you know it's timely to to to move uh
this through but like i said i'm gonna
support the amendment and the bill is
amended
any further comment
i have one comment i know you want to
move but i think at a time when we're
dealing with conval and some of those
other issues going on
it's a good time for the legislature to
step forward and say that we are working
in several zones to try to address the
opportunity for an adequate education
and
and this shows that we're not sitting
back on our on our heels and not we're
recognizing that
there are certain responsibilities we
have and certain learning areas that we
have a responsibility for and we're so
saying right here now that and we've
also said further by the interim study
we're doing with uh on the other side of
the coin with the dollar bill
funding
right and and uh and thank you mr chair
for
just i and and i agree with what
representative ladd said there the
conval case though however is about uh
whether or not um
uh new hampshire is is funding its
school schools in a constitutional way
and whether current funding um is uh is
is sufficient to cover the cost of an
adequate education and now we're
changing the definition of an adequate
education by putting a few more
block a few more things in the box
so so whether or not that will be looked
on
who knows how that's going to be looked
on by
by the by the court but but i absolutely
agree with with what representative ladd
is saying that that um
uh a bill like this but but and more
significantly a bill like like the
foundation opportunity plan shows the
court that the legislature is serious
about its um about its responsibility
and obligations to both define an
adequate education and fund it so
thanks
thank you see no further comments um
we'll take a uh hand poll on the uh
amendment
uh 1024
all supportive of the amendment please
raise their hand
it looks to be
and
if my math is correct it would be zero
opposed
so is there a further motion
representative led yeah i'd like to make
a uh a motion ought to pass this amended
with and i don't even have an amendment
in front of me 10 24
10 44 24 10 24 yes with yeah 10 24h
thank you uh
second
for that
representative nelson thank you
any further discussion seen none uh
representative nelson uh could you uh
take the role
okay the motion is what passed as
amended
representative cordelli yes
representative nader
yes representative johnson yes
yes
representative erstein yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes
representatives yes
reserve nelson yes representative jack
i'm sorry yes
yes
luna yes jack yes
jack all right
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison yes representative mullen yes
representative woodcock yeah
representative porter no
oh okay
representative hall
yes team representative
yes
uh representative porter is uh consent
okay with you
okay great no other objections
thank you very much uh we're gonna move
on now to hb 1499 relative charter
public school eligibility for student
building aid
1499.
representative uh hobson all right do
you have a motion
yes i'd like to make a motion of
autopass as amended and i have an
amendment
did i do it wrong again
is there a second
person like us
you want to speak to your motion yes i
just wanted to
point everyone to amendment 10268
we processed this amendment over lunch
and we have taken out
this amendment only amends section 2a
b and c are
back to the original format
in the original bill
uh
that
that was the one that i passed around
right after lunch
i should have like 200 extra copies
that's where they are
[Music]
okay at this point in time uh we're
gonna take a caucus
for uh five minutes please
i think i might have broken something
did i break something
i did that on purpose
he's pretty respected
we have a day off tomorrow right
i hope so
this is actually the chairs committee on
my career yeah we have that and
you
okay everybody's welcome back
okay at this point in time we're going
to continue with uh hb 1499 and i will
recognize representative hobson
so i would like to withdraw my motion
to ought to pass as amended for 14.99
and put forth a new do i need to do we
need to well you're gonna you're going
to withdraw not to pass because we you
were talking discussing
we hadn't gotten to the amendment thank
you for for
learning with me or allowing me to learn
here um so i will withdraw my motion
okay
is that going to agree i will withdraw
my second thank you
so i will recognize represent hobson for
a motion
i would like to put forth a motion of
interim study for hb
1499.
is there a second
i second thank you very much
is there a discussion
uh sure i'll just uh add that i think
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done um in some of understanding the
documents understanding
um the dissolution of charter schools
and uh
and uh building facilities and state aid
in general so
with that i will
stop thank you very much uh reference do
you have any
comments well just looking at the
discussion we had there's obviously a
lot of
not understanding and not clearness so
we need to make it clear thank you thank
you further discussion from the
committee
not seeing any uh
represent nelson are you about ready
representative
cordelli
yes representative
yes representative johnson yes yes
yes representative first team yes
representative hopson yes representative
ford yes representative
yes representative nelson yes
representative luna yes
representative jack yes representative
cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison yes representative mullen yes
representative woodcock yeah
representative porter
yes
representative hall yes representative
congratulations
consent consent everybody
okay thank you very much i'd like to uh
go to
1329 and i will hand the gavel over to
represent cordelia
thank you mr chairman this is house bill
1329 relative to the alternate
alternative programs for credit leading
to high school graduation
and i recognize chairman ladd for a
motion
i will recommend itl
uh do we have a second
representative luna thank you
um
discussion
chairman i have no discussion
uh representative
any committee discussion
scene none
um whenever the clerk's ready this is a
uh itl motion on 1329.
you guys are ahead of me
uh representative
cordelli
yes representative litchfield um not her
excuse me yes representative johnson yes
representative lucas yes representative
ernst yes i'll get it eventually
representative hopson
yes representative ford yes of soda
yes representative nelson yes
representative luna yes
representative jack yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner
yes representative ellison
representative mullen yes representative
woodcock yeah
representative porter yes representative
hall yes
representative vlad yes
good feeling
zero okay thank you
uh the next bill which uh
for me oh yeah any objections to consent
yeah
okay uh hb 1663
relative to requirements for home
education students we have been on that
prior to i believe today
did you make the notion on the last one
uh yes
okay
the assist going this way or that way
that way
hard to know at this point that's right
up from down
this is
erica's and glenn i think it's taking
the rule making out of it so that rule
making remains
that we have in place right now
that frank likes
so he'll explain it yeah but
what happened
did we have that on the table or did
no no i don't believe we did
so it's it's just discussion that's all
yeah
you're well organized
we have uh
hb 1663
uh that we're addressing right now we
have had discussion we have discussed
other amendments but we've never taken
any action on any of those amendments
so we are still with the original motion
on 1663 which was ought to pass
and so i'll repres uh i'll recognize
represent cordelia at this time
uh thank you miss chair i would move uh
ought to pass on amendment uh 1028 h
is there a second
representative seconds that
uh represent cordelia would you like to
speak to your motion uh yes thank you mr
chairman um
this
uh amendment
uh
corrects the problem that we saw
on the prior
amendment which was
that
uh the deletion of rules
was not removed in the pre prior
amendment and this amendment i believe
uh corrects that situation
um
and uh that should be the only change
further discussion from uh
representatives
if you care
not really no
i care but no discussion
thank you represent uh any any other
representatives that have comments or
questions
not seeing any
we're going to be then act on the
amendment
so we can do that
we can do the amendment by a show of
hands
so why don't you do that that way uh
representative
all those eyes please all the eyes
mr representative woodcock are you
no okay thank you
18 to 1.
okay
now we have in front of us the bill
um 1663 as amended with amendment 1028 h
further discussion
not seeing any uh representative nelson
okay one second 1663
as amended
representative cordelli yes
representative
yes representative johnson yes
yes representative bernstein yes
representative hopson
yes representative ford yes
representative soda yes representative
nelson yes
representative luna
yes
representative jack yes
representative
cornell yes
representative tanner
yes representative ellison
representative mullen yes representative
woodcock no
representative porter yes
yes
and representative lat yes
eighteen one
is consent okay with uh represent
woodcock
thank you
okay we're starting a little down i'm
counting one two
three
four
five bills left
maybe six
seven anyone that's it's modern math
i only
well let's start i i got six bills here
well that's that will
fire me
i do too
okay let's hit uh hb 1132 we have
several amendments on that bill this is
relative to applications for a charter
conversion school
she's
just amazing how the stuff disappears
um
uh
okay does everybody have a copy of these
things
it took me an hour to find the stuff too
um
copies on 9 7 0 h if anyone needs it
there is one 9 2
7 and 9 7 0.
that's the two that i have
i don't i had decided a hard time
finding one
extra
are there any on the table here in front
nine two seven
nine
yes
you
okay let's go ahead and and start uh
this
um
uh a bill right here dealing with 11 32
we do have two uh amendments in front of
us
who wants to make this motion
me
who's me
go ahead
i'd like to move otp on
11 32 and i'd like to introduce not just
to just make a motion that's the motion
ought to pass is there to pass i'll
second that
okay so we have the uh bill on the table
right now and before we go into any
specific
[Music]
amendment we'll have to open a
discussion
right now because there are two of them
right there one from myself and one from
rep san luno
there there's
two
differences but uh there well there's
several differences
uh one is this for uh conversion charter
schools everybody familiar with what a
conversion charter school is there's a
number of ways two ways the charter
school beca comes law
and the conversion charter school is the
one which is it's still underneath the
district it's a decision of the local
school district to go that direction
and it remains money comes through the
school district to that charter school
whereas the funding for the other
charter schools in our state comes from
a different account
and they're not beholding to the school
district
so this the one bill right here which is
mine requires a three-fifths vote
and it's both of my peers have
eliminated
the
the majority of its prospective teachers
have to give a vote two-thirds in the in
the written comments of the
superintendent principal
uh it looks like both bills
change that and and represent luna can
talk to us if there if there's more need
to be said
the his his bill
requires a two-thirds majority vote of
the
um school district at a rigger meeting
mine request requires a three-fist
that's a difference of what
um six percent
so it's not a heck of a lot of a lot of
difference
and in the school district at a regular
meeting or at a special meeting uh so
mine has the two meetings
uh the rest of the language
is it the same i
it looks it looks it to me
b is in current that's current law it's
in current law so it's kind of a you
know
more than what we really need in the
bill that i had there it's just the way
it shows you that the drafting snag the
drafters oftentimes do this it's
different for different people
so
i i i can live with either one of these
i think that a school district that's uh
wanting to go into the conversion
business
um
it should be done probably for sure i
think at the annual meeting
calling a special meeting you could get
fewer people there and you could you
could push this thing
a little easier and i think if you're
going to change and convert your school
district or your high school or whatever
level to a charter school this is a huge
huge
deal
and uh
we shouldn't hold any punches or you
know it should be done clearly that way
so
i i'm good with either direction here
represent porter
thank you mr chair and i i want to
congratulate you on that because yes you
can anybody can call a special district
a special meeting with just 50
signatures and even though the school
board has to approve it it is
better i think to take it as a matter of
course at a regular meeting
with plenty of preparation ahead of time
as would be done with those so i
congratulate you on saying that and that
would make me want to support
the amendment that it takes out special
means thank you very much representative
porter i appreciate it
i could call a special meeting in the
middle of summer when everybody's off in
istanbul or some when i'm not istanbul
uh hopefully hopefully ogunquit um
and uh so uh yeah and have few people
there and control things but at the
annual meeting which is done at the time
we all know there's a meeting i think
that's more in up and up
members of the committee for there's any
uh who seconded that thing
i no
i did okay
sorry it's getting late
so we need a motion on an amendment so
we need a motion on the amendment
so um so i i would move amendment um
970h
which um which
requires the two-thirds majority at a
regular annual meeting i'll second it
okay so we have an amendment on on the
uh
in front of us here um is there any
further discussion from members of the
committee
representing nelson
show of
show our hands please
the amendment number please could you
repeat that
nine seven zero h
all those in favor
unanimously
okay so we have the uh amendment
approved representative would you like
to make a motion you can write the blurb
[Laughter]
no okay actually um
alicia made the motion that's right
alicia would you right do you want to
write the blurb or do you want somebody
else all i have to do is change three
fifths to two-thirds in the blurb and
we're all set well then then no you okay
i already gave it to you
yeah which is fine i didn't put that in
there anyway so okay so um reps and like
us do you have a motion
yes i would like to move um ought to
pass with amendment
in the second
second okay so motion made by lycus and
second by um
cordelli uh any further discussion
yes representative ellison uh i raised
the question and i'm not sure who's who
answers this when we had earlier
discussions on a couple of occasions on
this bill
my question was about labor agreements
that would be in place
uh and for instance you could have a
three-year contract between
the teachers association and the school
board and the charter conversion vote
might take place
and therefore
does that then change the nature of that
labor agreement with the teachers who
end up being in the charter conversion
school
as opposed to the regular school
i thought we had that answered from
mr green when he's here or dr green
do you remember can you remember
represent woodcock
i do oh there you go
oh do you want the answer yeah okay um
what he said was that the the union can
continue
in the regular school
but those folks the teachers are under
union any union contract that goes into
the conversion school they may unionize
but they are not part of
that's exactly what he said i think yes
thank you for that clarification uh
based on that i'll be voting against the
bill uh because it raises the issue that
we have an existing labor contract which
would be abrogated for some people by a
charter conversion vote
and
i'm going to stand with my brothers and
sisters in the union movement on this
one
thank you
further discussion yes represent
woodcock
thank you chairman um
at the hearing on january 26
when we were discussing or you were
discussing presenting the initial bill
he said the purpose of the bill is to
save money it saves money by reducing
extra staff and outsourcing
and i asked about libraries he said we
have public libraries and we talked
about health and schools we have private
clubs
i have a real concern about
this
uh
bill not about the conversion but
conversion existing school
um because i think it beyond
representative
ellison's concern about the union being
hijacked turn the contract
i see it as a union buster to be honest
with you and not i'm sure that wasn't
your intent rick i see it as a union
buster because you get small school
districts we have say three elementary
schools you have group people say you
know what we can't afford the three
elementary schools so now we're going to
come together and we'll we're going to
we'll have one we'll make a conversion
charter school now we jump into those
teachers that are left well we can
renegotiate the salary because the
salary is changeable now and then we go
to a charter school where only 50
percent of the teachers in there have to
be certified teachers so it becomes a
huge
savings for that community and then if
you outsource any of the services the
tech services the librarian services
the purpose here is not to improve
education it wasn't converted into a
thematic charter school it was
recommended by the teachers it wasn't
something that came internal up this is
strictly a dollar savings i think it
puts public education and public
teachers and public education at risk i
don't i don't think this is a good bill
at all for those reasons um and i will
not be supporting it
further discussion
that's yes representatives
yes i just wanted to
say that it's not i don't i'm not sure
who said and it doesn't matter all about
money but
i see it also as giving the local town
more
options and flexibility with what they
do and how they run their school the
hours they run their school when they
are open all kinds of things that um
that doing a charter public school
because
you know would would open up to them and
they may want to try something new
thank you
further discussion
just one responsibility
that's why we have a china public school
process that's significantly different
from taking a public school right now
and converting it over
further discussion representative paul
yes thank you mr speaker mr speaker
listen to me mr chair
um
so right now can
can
this happen or not
well yes it can according to the statute
we have in place
uh we're this still right here would
modify that statute it makes it makes it
okay
okay any further discussion
mr clerk would you please uh call the
role
clarification we are
the previous adoption of nine seven zero
was 19 to zero
okay and now we're going to the full
bill with amendment nine seven zero
correct that's this one okay
representative cordelli
yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson yes representative lucas yes
representative bernstein yes
representative hopson yes representative
ford yes representative soda yes
representative nelson yes
representative luna
yes
representative
jack no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no representative
mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter no representative
hall no
and representative lads yes okay
eleven
two eight
okay so what i'd like to do now is just
read the bills off that i are
you're doing the majority
um
i'm going to read off the bills which i
don't have down as having done yet
if somebody else is keeping a record
let's see if we gel
uh i have hb 1131 still to do
okay going down the list hb 1233 yet to
do
maybe it's wishful thinking
um
hb 1241 yet to do
okay
hb 13
hb
1376 yes
that's what i've got
that's right we didn't we didn't finish
that that's right i have a no there okay
thank you
yes yes yes
okay
let's uh
we started 1513
relative to the definition of a child
with a disability for purposes of
special education
let's just hammer in that one again
right now
you uh should have an amendment mr chair
everybody should have when i passed it
out when we got back from lunch
it's 1 0 2 0 h
okay
so that's 15-13
do you want any extra copies of anywhere
around here
copies
okay uh reps and mullen can you explain
what we got here in one zero two zero
eight do we have a motion on the floor
we have uh ought to pass right i think
we had it on the previous amendment yeah
so we had to opt to pass to get the bill
introduced now
right yeah so i ought to pass was on the
floor i don't think we had i we might
have discussed the amendment but i don't
think we called it that's right so yeah
okay go ahead okay so for uh your
entertainment purposes i have uh
amendment 1020h
known as the jennifer iv helps me
amendment
what i have done is smoothed out the
language around the two changes that are
being made
it now reads child with a disability
means any person from the age of three
to the atta age at the end of the school
calendar year
during which the student turns 21
and then again further down in the bill
it talks about child with a disability
shall include a person from the age of
18 to the age attend attained at the end
of the school calendar year
and that has to do with existing law for
really young adults that are still in
special education programs
and or left school and or are
incarcerated
the effective date remains july 1
are you 2023 a motion on that i will
make a motion i will make a motion of uh
we are we doing just the bill
we didn't do it not to pass on the bill
itself right
oh i thought we had okay
so
what we need to do is have a motion
15 13 15 13.
i'll uh represent cordelli
sir second
represent moan
so we have a motion
uh ought to pass
on this bill 1513 made by cordelia and
second by mullen
any uh further discussion on the part of
representative cordelli
nothing further rep samoan
represent mullen you're recognized for a
motion
uh i would like to move uh amendment
1020h
to house bill 1513 ought to pass
is there a second
reps and like us
okay you have discussed
i have discussed it at length if anybody
has any further questions please feel
free to let me know
are there any questions
it's free
i don't see any okay
any further discussion
represent nelson
at one point we had another amendment we
withdrew that one zero
307 or zero three eight
we never moved
we discussed and saw some technical
stuff with it already and the motion is
ought to pass as amended
on the amendment okay
thank you very much
yes all those in favor say raise your
hand
all those opposed
19-0
you're gonna make a promotion so he
promised to get the blurb to me
are you looking at me because you
believe i can be counted on to get the
verb
it's already been done representative
cordelli uh made the motion
okay
oh okay
i'm
tired you don't have a three and a half
year old running around your house no
thank god
uh i would move uh to pass as amended on
uh house bill 1513.
is there a second
second set
further discussion
all those
represent all the rep reference and
nelson no way many more okay
all righty let's go on with the fun here
representative cordelli
yes representative knotter
yes representative johnson yes
representative lucas yes
representative first team yes try it
that way
representative hopson yes representative
ford yes representative soda yes
representative nelson yes representative
luna yes
representative check yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
ellison yes representative mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter yes representative
hall yes
representative vlad yes okay
19-0
okay what i'm going to start doing now
is just working down on consent by the
way good for consent okay i'm just going
to start walking down through it in the
order cry in the numerical order they
come up in
so it looks like the first one we
haven't done is 11 31.
okay
okay so
[Music]
let's have then plain discussion with no
uh um you know amendment put forward for
five or ten minutes here
all right
this goes around okay
very good
well we have a second while everybody's
getting stuff distributed uh going over
the
bills we did yesterday
i still don't have the committee reports
or the minority reports or the majority
reports in from
um let's see
yeah from you from boom
tanner
and mullen
you got it over there okay
so if you have those minority over you
okay send us and when you do everything
else then and i'll contact ralph
okay uh okay i recognize uh
uh
yeah for discussion purposes
um
on amendment 0 9 9 h excuse me 9 9 8 h
um the only change um is in relation to
uh questioning that came up during the
hearing about
other public entity online 17 and 18
and we changed that
to other public education agency
um which is
defined in statute
and that
includes
schools school districts school boards
public academies are all
um
defined within
public education agency
so we felt that that fits
um in here and covers all the bases
and for
that's it on that part
amendment yeah so on the other amendment
uh
linda yes
uh thank you this is amendment one zero
zero three h and
i too uh just eliminated
the um in it entity uh so it says it uh
um
let's see
uh it any any person claiming to be
aggrieved
including attorney general may initiate
civil action against the school school
district or school board in superior
court i i just took out other entity and
then i dropped
the third paragraph because again i see
no reason
um that that be there
uh because the educator is just doing
what the the superintendent and school
uh policy is
and um they're just in in
doing their job and the other thing is
that i really am offended by taking um
the code of conduct and making it you
know um
a tool
uh to attack so
um that's why i took that section out
okay
i think the code of conduct was good but
when you use it as
a sledgehammer like this it's it's just
not appropriate i don't think
is there any further discussion from
committee members
yes represent mullen
thank you mr chair um i'm going to go
back to
my concern that i expressed yesterday
over the superintendent of schools being
taken out of the chain of command
maybe in both of these at this point no
uh sorry just in representative
cordelie's uh amendment
we had some discussion in here about the
role of the board of trustees in a
chartered school with regards to the
daily operation
i'm looking at page 592
in our law book where it says
chartered public schools authority and
duties of the board of trustees roman
numeral one
unless otherwise provided in this
chapter the board of trustees of a
chartered public school upon issuance of
its charter
shall have general supervisory control
and authority over the operations of the
chartered public school
and then on page 600 under
194b roman 13
chartered public schools operations it
says
the board of roman three the board of
trustees in consultation with teachers
and the principal shall determine the
chartered public schools curriculum and
develop the annual budget
roman four the board of trustees shall
be considered the public employer for
the purposes of collective bargaining
so i i think that this uh portrayal that
we had yesterday that the board of
trustees is only about the financial
operation of a charter school was not
a complete picture
and so um my concern is that you've got
a school board
from the public school making this
determination
and not the superintendent
the chief executive officer of the
chartered public school
but not the board of trustees
so
i i think there's an inconsistency there
between the governance of the two
entities and uh i i just
i i have a i have a hard time
understanding that
thank you uh ref sent cordelli uh thank
you i um neglected to point out one
other thing in this amendment because it
was based on a prior amendment
but in
h
non-public schools are not
included in this
whereas in
representative tanner's amendment 1003
non-public schools
are
included
in that and i think that that's a
significant difference
okay further discussion from the
committee
may i just make a statement about the
non-public school um it's each
accredited non-public schools so i
assume that's through the
department of education
um and it may be schools that are
contracted
with public schools so
that's right why it's still there
we do have some
private schools which are accredited
that are totally separate apart from
you know public schools
that's that system you know
for example like holderness school
it's a private school
but it's unto itself too the plymouth
high school takes all the kids
so um
they're in and and holderness is of
course credited
through nichi so is it also approved by
the state
uh i i
couldn't tell you that i get confused
with
um accreditation which i know is through
the you know third party
um new england association new england
association of schools and colleges
um and
the approval by this by the state
department of education which approves
non-public schools for tuition purposes
and and so i get kind of confused
between those two
yeah the the commission has the
authority to do that too and i i just
don't know if it's been done i know it
was done like for fryeburg academy that
was done
that's not in our state but the
commissioner has the authority to
approve that school the the
educate the new hampshire commissioner
yes and then
um and holderness could be approved by
the department of education if it was
taking yeah
so
yes go ahead rep
yes
thank you um
one of the topics that was just brought
up was that the superintendent was being
bypassed the superintendent reports to
the school board the school board
dictates what the superintendent does
so whether he's in here or not
the superintendent has to report to the
school board the school board is the
superintendent's boss
right
i recognize that representative johnson
thank you for clarifying that my
question was not
my question was it looks like we've got
one head of building or one head of
of staff and not the board in charge in
one situation
the school board and not the
superintendent
in the other situation we've got the
person who's in charge you know the the
principal the the head of the charter
school and not the board of trustees i i
what i was saying was that i would have
thought
that it would have been uh the school
board and the board of trustees
or
the chief operating officer and the
superintendent but not one in one
situation and one in the other
further discussion
okay we're
yes
so just just quickly mr chair so um
looking at the original bill and looking
at at both amendments the original bill
talks about accredited non-public
schools property on line seven
the tanner bill
of tanner amendment um i think repeats
that same that same accredited
non-public school property and the
the cordelli one eliminates the
accredited non-public it only refers to
to these these schools property
referring to the
the you know what's discussed in line
five six five five and six but on the
original bill and on the tanner
amendment when it talks about an
accredited non-public schools property
is is
does that mean netchie accredited or
does that mean department approved
it's wide open there's a lot of
accrediting organizations it's not just
the new england associate various
christian accrediting agencies and right
and it goes on so so but i i think in
the cu
in the context of what 1131 is is
looking to do
a credit
whether they're academically accredited
is less
relevant than whether they're department
approved for providing um the the
content of an adequate education because
that's the approval standards that we
that we considered in
that's the approval standard right
you're approved to deliver
an adequate education
so so um
in the original bill and in the tanner
amendment
would it make sense that they're really
referring to approved
non-approved non-public schools
non-public schools who can deliver an
adequate education um
undercurrent to meet the minimum public
standards for public schools
right right it's really approval not
accreditation yeah
yes
go ahead
my understanding from the
board of the
some representative
of the doe
was that that approval
is for the attendance part
is is it not i mean
when they went to court over this i was
at the court case and they were saying
that it was for attendance
so in order to be in order to say so a
kid isn't delinquent they can go to a
public school or they can go to a
private school that's approved by the
state and the state said that's what
they were approving it
for that it was adequate and yeah they
have to fill out all kinds of paperwork
and submit all their stuff and
everything but
it's still a private school
and should we be
putting laws like this on a private
school it's it's not a publicly funded
it's not in anything it's still private
schools should we be
putting laws on private entities
i'm i'd have to go back and look at into
the rules but there's two different
levels of approval
now you can have the uh
minimum
the what i have in front of me right
here the public school approval
standards right here uh
minimum standards for public school
approval there's another level which is
lesser than this
and i'm just trying to recall all these
for attendance approval for attendance
but there's other areas within
attendance which also deal with some of
the basic safety issues and that
codes that were of health and
that type of thing is in that level of
attendance approval
we we dealt with that when we were
looking at tuition tuition programs in
our schools
yes representative cordelli
um thank you uh yeah i think that uh
representative uh lakers uh um
touched on it in that uh
um i think one of the problems with the
original bill
was the
inclusion of the non-public schools and
i know in discussion
with
at least one of the sponsors
they agreed with that
and that it probably should be removed
so that's
one of the things i tried to accomplish
in these
plus
i think was representative ladd had a
question about what other entity um was
referring to so that's why we made the
other change
mr chair yes
so so i looked up the
the
rsa that this bill refers to uh 189
colon 10
and it adds a new section to it but the
sec
it doesn't make any sense that it's even
there
that section is called is titled studies
um and it says the school board shall
ensure the health education and physical
education are taught to pupils as part
of the basic curriculum
and it just it goes down and itemizes
the things that should be taught in
health and phys ed
um
and and then
all of a sudden this bill appears
or would appear right after that just
it's
looks totally out of place
where it is i
at this point i would say that
maybe it needs
to go back to the drawing boards that um
or have interim study
well i tend to agree with you on that um
i i think that
uh what we've done with
much of our statutory language we pluck
stuff into certain areas and this is one
which i've spoken to in the last several
days quite often
that this is an area that we need to be
parking
some of the definition further what
these studies are in fact even when i
was talking about 1671 today i mentioned
the word studies
we have the learning areas but within
learning areas you have certain studies
and that's where we parked health
physical education some of the issues
with health and we've also now parked in
um
personal finance literacy in there as
far as how to embed it and how to tie it
into your
your your learning areas
so there and there's need to do we also
have instruction in there the history of
our country and and some of the civics
is parked in the 189 section
um
it would seem that this would be under
safety or health and safety of the
buildings food and nutrition is there
you go on through everything in 189 447
is the page i have yeah
yes
it says
new section
and it puts it after not in but after
as a new section after section 10 the
following news section and so
that whole section has all kinds of
things not just studies
whatever you want to make of that i i
got that and i understand that 189 is
about school board superintendents
teachers truant officers and school
census
that's the whole name of that chapter
so
but we're going to see things right
beside like this and it's just makes it
seem kind of convoluted and hard to
follow but yeah you're right it is a
separate section
separate section but it's under studies
yes that's right it's
it would be uh 10a which would be 189
a so it's right yeah 18910 is studies
right
with within with a new title facial
covering policy
but the major title for
well it 189.00 talks about what the
school board has to do it shall do this
it shall do that and that's what all the
other ones have said within studies
okay so we got to get beyond the
discussion point here we're gonna have
to have a motion put on the floor so we
can start moving here so represent
cordelia do you have a motion all right
to pass
on house one one one three
is there a second
julius uh represents
cytos uh
okay okay do you care to
talk to your
uh
just uh the fact that um
even in discussion with uh one of the
sponsors uh we recognized the issue of
including non-public schools in here
and that
generated the
thought for uh amendment
further discussion yes representative
woodcock
just two points i'd like to reiterate i
concur with representative tanner on the
violation of section three
um that deals with teachers teachers are
under the jurisdiction of the
the
the school principal and and the
administration
and to have them have disciplinary
options additionally infractions on the
record uh even after as far as the state
board because they've fallen what
they're supposed to be doing i think
that's a real conflict there and very
difficult for the teachers to do know
what to do and i also agree that it
doesn't make any sense to me starting
adding something that is a health and
safety issue
under a studies category when we know
it's in the wrong place to start with
thank you
thank you further discussion
yes
represent mullen
with regards to that teacher code of
conduct i i i mean it specifically says
that the state board of education is
going to weigh in on this
and um
yeah i mean
it's there's a graduated ladder of
disciplinary measures is that taken into
account in this
if it's going to reference to that code
it would
uh reps uh
representative
diane are you willing to come up and
take a few questions
so
so my question is that we've we've had
discussion before on the code of ethics
this year
and yeah well the yeah the code of
conduct the the
the others assurance but
um
is
when we we discussed the the prior bill
it was decided that
we wouldn't as legislature get into the
business of trying to
craft or write language now this is not
crafting any language
this is saying that you do this you're
going to it's going to be there's going
to be this as a response possibly
um
how's this fit in with the code of
conduct
is it something which should be done
another way than we're doing here or is
this an appropriate of course we can do
legislatively we can do it but i'm just
trying to find out where does it stand
in terms of
compatibility with what we did in the
last bill
thank you so for the record diana fenton
with the department of education so the
code of conduct was established and it
is in 21
and
do you need a copy i do actually um
so statutorily
it's in
21 and nine i believe and it sets out
the four
um
principles
that were
discussed in the statute and then those
were then
codified created in rulemaking and
within each principle those four
principles there's five actually in the
code of conduct but the fifth is a duty
to report but the four substantive
principles
set out the the violations
um
tries to for us to be
modifying the code of ethics through
this venue or through uh rulemaking
so to clarify you would be amending the
code of conduct the code of ethics does
not actually actually
code of conduct i know i know you did um
so
ultimately
it is up to this committee but rule
making is what created the document that
you have in front of you
and it is rule making that allowed the
department if you think about what was
passed by this committee
in
2016 or 2017
it was four basic principles and in fact
you were
you were the sponsor of that
representative lad and and you
enumerated the four areas that you
wanted the department to take action on
and you gave us the blueprint
and then the department took it via
rulemaking which was in the statute
obviously and
elaborated upon those and we did so with
our stakeholder partners
so
in keeping in that spirit that is
certainly one way
this legislative body could
effectuate this intent in in
paragraph three
is to is to put it into
rulemaking are there further questions
represent tanner
thank you diane yes
please
um
do you think that or
i don't know how to put this as a
question
um do you
think that the that any intent in the
code of conduct
was made to penalize a teacher for
following the policies of the school
district
so
when the code of conduct was created
um
there was and there continues to be a
very bright line between employment
and licensure
and
that is the way the code of conduct has
been interpreted and we have that
discussion
on a consistent basis within the
department of education there are
actions that come before us for
consideration which we deem to be
employment
so i will give you an example
um
the department was contacted um with a
concern that there was an educator an
administrator who uh was not returning
um
their their phone call their their email
right
and
the parent was was upset and
understandably so
um and the parent requested that
the department look at this matter um
the facts were very clear
and and
wanted action to be taken on that
person's credential and the decision was
made that that's not the intent of the
code of conduct
um that was an employment issue
the depart the district can deal with
that however they see fit if they see
that as a issue of professionalism they
can deal with that that's not a
credentialing issue
um when the code of conduct was created
it was created
as a recognition of the importance of
child safety period
that's it and we recognize that
if departments deal with educators who
should not be around children
exclusively as a matter of employment
then those educators will go from
district to district to district and
that is what the code of conduct was
intended to prohibit and that is in
large part how the code of conduct has
been and will be
interpreted we are held to our
precedence of how we interpret that
moving forward and so yes
i appreciate the question because we
always go back to that delineating line
is this employment or is this licensure
another example briefly that i will give
you because i know we're getting to be
near four o'clock um we had a gentleman
who
uh was accused of of
misappropriating um
those hvac
like this big
whatever those are called those air
filters in the back of the room shows my
knowledge base um he
took that from the school allegedly he
took it from the school and brought it
home and
kept it for a while and brought it back
and the district handled that the
district imposed whatever they thought
was appropriate the department reviewed
it we made a determination
that that's not that's that's employment
it's employment it's not going to uh
affect the license and so we always keep
that in mind and that's a long answer to
a short question
yes there will always be a line i always
use myself as an example
i'm a licensed attorney
but i'm employed by the state of new
hampshire in the department of education
and there are things that i do that that
could affect my employment
right there are things that i do testify
to um i can tell you my computer which
is state property
has a beautiful picture of my child when
you pop it up super cute it's adorable
i'm sure it violates an i.t policy
right but he's super cute so it's okay
and this is being recorded
so
i played the fifth
um
but right could that be an issue
employment wise yes if i violate a dress
code policy yes if i don't show up to
work yes if
right commissioner edible can probably
find a whole host of things um
employment employment employment but it
doesn't necessarily equal a violation of
my license to practice law
if however i was submitting false travel
to say oh yes i went to
a training in portsmouth today rather
than here in concord and here is my
travel state of new hampshire please
reimburse me that's theft
and that would be reportable to the new
hampshire bar and could take action on
my license and so that is the framework
or a work policy is going to rise to
that level to say
you should not teach anywhere
um thank you for that answer
more than you more than you bargained
for no i think it puts it out i would
also ask do you think that
using somebody's credential
their ability to
um
use their degree and their expertise and
their
livelihood to take that away
um
is
is a a strong weapon
that shouldn't be used only in
in
really extreme cases that are like you
said um theft uh you know child abuse uh
you've you've outlined some in the code
of conduct and that
simply following uh the school
district's mask policy if their mass
policy happens to be under um
discussion or
diversion or whatever by the the public
or by the you know uh
brought to the attention that that's the
district
and that the teacher is simply following
that policy that that isn't something to
weaponize their credential against
i
i think that's that is a policy
consideration for this legislative body
and
and i will hesitate to go beyond that
line but what i can tell you is again
the code of conduct was created for a
certain purpose and it was created out
of recognition um
that there are some high-level issues
that the state agency has to become
involved in
and we recognize that there is a
difference between employment and
licensure there simply is and i always
use myself as an example which one of
these days is going to get me in trouble
and today might be that day
um
you know
if i were to be fired
that's one thing right but i go and i
work as a lawyer in another capacity
maybe i hang out my shingle maybe i go
work for morgan and morgan who knows
there's a whole host of things i can do
um
i can still function in that role as an
attorney
if
i lose my license
to practice law that is a very different
analysis
so
again we carry that same idea over and
and all agencies that regulate licenses
have that same basic analysis and if you
go to the oplc it's the same thing
thank you
so
dianne if a school board enacts this
policy
and if i'm a teacher in the classroom
and i want to keep my job
so i'm going to also enforce that policy
um
so
the teacher is the one that's caught
saying you know
and and going to be reprimanded because
they're the one with the ticket with the
certification
but
um
is the the teacher didn't instigate the
policy
the teacher was doing what he or she has
just been told to do by
the boss
so
can in fact in a situation like this how
would this code
can the code of a conduct be
used
against that teacher for something one
hand you you damned if you do and damned
if you don't that's the situation the
person's in
so how do we avoid that from occurring
yeah i don't know
um i mean
again i i would encourage this body to
recognize the difference between
employment and licensure and all i can
tell you is that um
that that's the design and the
underpinnings of the code of conduct and
i think
throughout this pandemic the department
has received numerous complaints on
masks no masks all these different
policies and how they were handled at
the local level we have gotten an
enormous number of calls on this as
this legislative body can only imagine
and the department has consistently said
that's a school board policy decision
and the superintendent or the teacher or
the administrator was simply following
the policy
and and it
there was no action for the department
to take
um
if this legislative body wants to to
change that then i would suggest we that
it go into rule making so that it can
mirror
um
what was done with the code of conduct
represent cordelli
representative mullen thank you um
but it's not just a matter of
if a teacher is following the policy
it's if they're not following the policy
also
is one and secondly um
in terms of a complaint to the
department under the code of conduct um
there are other uh
actions that can be taken other than uh
pulling a license is that correct oh
that is absolutely correct yes uh and
thank you for that we have three forms
of
um of of sanction uh i always say
there's four actions and three forms of
sanction so the first action is we close
out the case no action taken and we do
that um the allegations unfounded or
unsubstantiated what have you
a revocation is reserved in large part
for
individuals who are having inappropriate
sexual relationships with students we've
seen that in the in the news you've
heard of those
and that is a permanent removal of that
person's license a suspension is a set
period of time in which that person is
removed from the classroom
and then there is a reprimand the
reprimand is a written warning it's
simply between the department and the
individual and there's and the license
the credential remains valid
um
and so we we think of reprimands i think
of them as kind of the rumble strip on
the highway right just kind of leads you
guides you back into your lane but the
credential remains valid yes
we we have that ability
representative mullin thank you mr chair
and thank you attorney finn for taking
my question
so i guess
my
follow-up question to that
bit of information that you just shared
is that when the department determines
whether it's a reprimand or a revocation
or a suspension or whatever
is that considered a disciplinary
sanction by the state board of education
and
if not then what is the significance of
the language
justifies disciplinary sanction by the
state board of education
so representative mullen looking at this
language
i interpret this language to mean
action taken under the code of conduct
by by the department
the state board of education
is the
global entity if you will that issues
the credential
the department is acting on behalf of
the state board of education and we've
had that discussion and other scenarios
and other contacts that we act on the
department acts on behalf of the state
board and so
it is the state board of education that
we kind of oversee all of that and when
that comes into play
we had a case
in which the educator
um
challenged the department's findings
challenged the offer of the discipline
and went to a hearing and then
challenged that finding to the state
board of education and so the state
board had the final say and that's
that's our process that is due process
that is how we build it in um but when i
read this
to me my interpretation falls right into
the the code of conduct yes other
further representative
thank you very much mr chair um and
thank you very much miss and for
sticking with us this afternoon so um
question i've got sort of goes back to
what representative tanner was asking
about earlier which is
the the section of law that that this
bill
amends
which is 189.10 and i was wondering does
the department actually have rulemaking
authority
under 189.10
so representative luna based on my
quick look at 189.10
in this section
i
i do not see a reference to 189
or
strike that i do not see the statutory
reference to rsa 541a which is the
rulemaking authority right and when we
look at rulemaking authority it has to
be explicitly stated in the statute
and it is helpful if it also says
what the parameters of that rulemaking
authority are and we saw that
with career and technical education we
went back and looked at our rules and i
know that's not relevant to this
conversation but i don't see it in
188910 and i don't see that reference in
1 89 10
a
but i
if i missed it i apologize but
to the best of my knowledge i just don't
see that okay and a follow-up on that
and so so based on um
based on
ed rules
and i think i'm looking in 5 11
somewhere which is the
code the the rules for for the code of
conduct
it
it says the following shall be
considered
aggravating circumstances
um
and seriousness offense the credential
holder's prior disciplinary record
um
uh the the credential holders lack of
willingness to cooperate the potential
harm to public health and safety and the
purpose of the rule violated so so if in
fact the the code of conduct is there's
going to be considered to be a violation
it would have to be in rules
and and for this
um for this section
to be
relative connected to rules there would
have to be rule making authority does
that
logic sort of flow
would there be a connection if
you're looking at the terminology code
of ethics which is in this bill would
that verbitch relate it back to 21n
which is has 541 within
but doesn't reference 189
other sections 189 do have rule making
authority
so
looking at at section three because it
references the educator code of conduct
i would certainly argue that the 511s
the administrative rules 511 that talks
about our policy
that we follow
when we administer the the code of
conduct so i i would certainly argue
that the 511s are are applicable because
this references the educator code of
conduct
are there further questions of the
department represent tanner yeah i have
just one more here so if i take this
bill
and i kind of
chop it down to its skeletal area as as
it looks to this
section three
um the first part is that the meat of
the bill is that that nobody in this
listing
shall adapt and force or implement a
policy that requires basically mass of
students and and other people that's the
meat of the top one
down in section three it says violation
of this section so um by an educator
shall be considered a violation of the
educator's code of conduct so it's
saying if i
enforce or implement a policy
that my school board has it
under this bill
it becomes a violation of the code of
conduct it's rewriting the code of
conduct and putting that specific
violation in there is that how you would
read this bill
yes i agree with that interpretation
further discussion with
representatives
so when it says educator
that includes the administrators right
that is how we have interpreted the code
of conduct yes
so
if a school board
followed this law and did not implement
masks
and a
principal
decided that in my school or the
superintendent decided in all my schools
we are going to have masks
how would that
i mean
wouldn't that be as an educator
and
the violation would be because they
didn't follow the school board and
didn't follow the law this law right i
how would that work
so based on that hypothetical
um
then
yes
i mean again based on that hypothetical
the department could in theory take
action upon the
superintendent's
credential yes the code of conduct was
rent written and intended to be
applicable to both educators and
administrators and our actions have
supported that interpretation yes thank
you
further discussion or the
department
but then i'm going to just take a five
minute break here ten minute break and
come back i think some of us have to get
up
we'll come back
there may be a horrible flower mark
downstairs
everything else
i understand the commissioners
okay we're ready go ahead
for purposes of moving i'd like to have
representative cordelli make a motion
please
yes
on the amendment
thank you
i would like to
move
amendment
998 h
uh
ought to pass
is there a second
representative julius
is there
a discussion from the make of the motion
um i think we've had quite a bit of
discussion already
you don't want to talk it's your
opportunity
okay no is there further discussion
yes
um thanks very much so um
it's my understanding that that in the
last few days the uh the department has
um
has um uh told uh school boards or
through their superintendents that uh
that know that schools cannot have any
um are prohibited from any mask
requirements and i'm wondering if we
need this bill what authority did the
department have to
to
make that declaration
is that a question to us right here
today
i i think that maybe you want to ask
that question as a commissioner i i well
maybe i could ask it of the
commissioner's attorney
hello um i understand from a
representation from nea that that was
recently stated i'm just not aware of
that
um
and i can i can get you that information
but it can't be
at this very second i i i understand
that but but is there any sort of
underlying um either ruler or statute
that supports the commissioners um
um
at least what we've heard is a
declaration to school boards through
their superintendents that such policies
are
that's really not related to this bill
it is related to this bill because i
think that's what this bill um goes at
and and um and the the the question here
is if this bill is necessary then then
the department overstepped its bounds
and and um and if this bill isn't
necessary
then um then why why would we proceed
with it
i think
that's right yeah yeah and i think
that's you know maybe i'm jumping the
gun because we're so
actually we haven't voted on the
amendment but
um i think we'll
vote on the amendment and quickly vote
on the bill
um but i think it goes to
if
whether we need the bill or not
if your question is
what is the authority um that the
commissioner acted
under in issuing a mandate
the short answer is i'm not sure because
i'm not sure
what he ordered this
school districts to do um my
understanding is nea
made that statement so they might know
better than i do
i'm just not in a position to answer
that question unfortunately
i i don't know the context in which it
was given
you don't know the context which the the
mandate that the commissioner made to
school boards through their
superintendents was good
no i don't know anything i don't know
anything about that okay
thank you
okay uh are there thank you very much
you're welcome
tanner
thank you i just i just once again want
to say and this isn't for uh represent
or attorney fenton but once you
weaponize the code of conduct
you lose all credibility
with me and teachers across the state
and what was sold to us
as um
something that was going to be helpful
make kids safe is now
being weaponized for a violation of
following the policies of your school
i i just i can't wrap my head around why
anybody would vote for this amendment
with that particular paragraph there
thank you very much
represent cordelli
tired
i think it's more an issue of um when
they don't
follow the policy
if someone mandates
masks
that
is not authorized um and i i think the i
don't know anything about the um
call that uh you know the commissioner
might have had with
someone or some people um all i know is
that the governor departments of health
and the department of education
said that mass use should be based on
individual choice
but if a school or the teacher is
mandating
it in their school or their classroom i
think that's where the issue is and
that's why this bill is needed
further discussion
i i'm just going to state my position on
it that i think that
an employee that's following
board directive
if there's some kind of an action that's
taken for whatever may be occurring
and if you are following that board
directive
then the responsible
entity
should be the board
not the teacher because the teachers in
an employment status and they're doing
what they did uh supposed to be doing
when i was
in the service
and my boss my boss was a one-star
general i was with him six seven eight
hours a day
when i was told to do something i did it
and i saw some things which were not
what i should be doing
but i did it
and that's
what you're taught in the military now
this is not the military we're talking
about schools here we're talking about
employment but it's a similar type
situation
so i i i'm of the opinion and i will
publicly announce it that
that
if in fact
that employee is told to do something
and that's in accordance with that board
policy
uh unless it's some kind of a borders
criminal
uh i will probably follow through what
i've been told to do
and and i'll let the cards fall
and hopefully uh reasonable people would
come in and say that the educators not
to lose the credential here
um
or e or to be reprimand i know there's
three levels and we've recommended
through letter a fourth
uh confidential letter placed in the
file or a confidence letter to the
teacher or to the employee because it's
not just teachers this is principles
administrators everybody has a ticket
so thank you
mr chair yeah um so you know with with
that representative ladd why wouldn't we
move forward with
um
amendment 1003
103h
that that that eliminates the um the
takes the code of conduct
out of the picture here it still
contains the um the right of the
right of private action
um for basically anybody to initiate
civil action against a school school
district or school board in superior
court for injunctive legal or equitable
relief
why wouldn't we just leave it at that
because when i look at the
the other amendment which we're not
talking about at the moment
i'm not supportive of this uh being
applied to
non-public schools
and and so you know they're they're i'm
looking at both of them from you know
there's parts of each um
and regardless how this filters out um
you know we're gonna have to live with
it or vote contrary on the house floor
however you want to vote your conscience
there but
that's how i respond to your question
there i think it's i'm
oppositional to the part where we're
referencing accredited non-public school
um
i i don't think that's necessary to have
in the bill at all
okay and and and i no i i certainly
recognize your position on that
recognize your your position
seems to be generally opposed to the
roman 3
section
of it certainly if it's used if a if a
if uh if an educator is following school
board policy
um
and i think we're probably running out
of time in terms of amendments on this
bill
but again i think that's that's another
indicator that um that a committee with
103 bills
and
passing something that just isn't ready
for for prime time it's uh
neither one of these amendments may be
maybe um maybe ready
and um
and i think that's that's it's very very
legitimate to
to you know vote your conscience on an
itl on this bill
okay is there further discussion we do
have a
motion yes
i've heard it said before that um
perhaps the other body could clean it up
if we just pass it
yeah see it's also contrary to you know
i i we try to send as as much because
that other body sometimes doesn't clean
it up they mess it up more
so
the other side of the wall sometimes the
other side of the wall
and a good group of people but
it doesn't always work
for those who've been around seen in a
while it's it's crazy world we live in
so
um
any further discussion
okay
i think we're ready to call the roll on
this one
i'm sorry i'm gonna go by
show of hands on the amendment uh zero
nine nine
eighty
all those in favor say aye
okay all those opposed no
so now do we have a
motion let's see that was the motion on
the amendment
um
represent cordelia would you like to
make a motion yes ought to pass
um as amended with uh amendment number
zero nine nine eight h
is there a second
represent lakers
represent saudi do you want to make that
thank you
further discussion
mr claire
a rep santana
um out of a hundred and
what is it 320 something like that bills
this one is the worst
okay rep
represent nelson is there any for the
discussion
would you please call the roll
thank you mr chairman
representative cordelli yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson
yes representative
yes representative bernstein yes
representative hopson
yes representative ford
yes representative soda yes
representative nelson yes
representative jack i'm sorry lunoff
no
representative jack no
representative cornell no representative
tanner absolutely not okay
representative ellison
representative mullen no representative
woodcock
representative porter
you're
not here representative hall
no
okay and representative yes
10-8
okay uh
bill hb 1233 prohibiting higher
education who's making anybody making uh
right yeah
yeah linda will do the
linda you wanna yeah
okay
hb 1233
reps like us do you have a motion
i move in where i'm steady
is there a second
12 33
okay represent codelli seconds it uh
represent leicas would you like to speak
to your motion 1233
yes i um
very much liked the idea of this bill
but in
hearings we did hear that there were
some issues with the way it was worded
it wasn't worded as well as some of
these other bills where we have said
except for
you know where it was needed for
visiting like nursing homes or
whatever as part of instruction and so
i would like to see this cleaned up and
hand it back
further discussion
yes representative thanks mr chair yeah
i think just like um what was the bill
we just did
one one three one this is a public
school um
haters bill and um and so uh i don't
think it's worthy of interim study i
think it's worth a a dumpster fire
and um and should be
thrown there
immediately um so
i'm going to support an itl on this
yes
i take extreme objection to that this
was prohibiting higher education
institutes so how that had to be a
public school haters bill i would love
to know
okay
further discussion
uh representative nelson we have uh a
motion on the floor
uh interim study
on 1233
that was made the motion was made by
the lagos okay
okay
there we go
represented and the motion is
interim study interim study
okay representative
cordelli
yes
representative nutter yes
representative johnson yes
representative lucas yes representative
yes representative hopson yes
representative ford yes representative
soda yes represent nelson yes
representative luno no
no
representative jack yes
okay yes so we have a yes as jack and i
know as
luna is that correct everybody's all set
all right oh you haven't finished yet
cornell no
no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no
representative mullen no
representative woodcock representative
porter
right here representative hall no
okay representative ladd yes
11 to 70.
okay next bill
um
who's doing that
okay say that again please uh
12 41 next bill prohibiting a school
district from mandating a covet 19
vaccination for school attendance
12.41
okay representative cordelli
is there a second
representative
representative cordelli do you want to
discuss your motion uh yes thank you um
i think that this bill is needed because
there is another bill
pending in the house
that would require
vaccination in order to attend a public
school
further discussion
yes represent uh what talked
about thank you
and i don't want you folks discuss this
yes i wasn't here
um
but i
i don't see the the value of this bill
when
the the bigger essence of the bill
beyond the the vaccination is the fact
that we continue to say
you guys keep flipping you know like
hamburgers over here your local
controller you know local control you
local control you know control let's
help local let's not help local i mean i
don't know what's out of the fence
you're on anymore this is another local
control issue it's a local schools local
parents local schools local tech dollars
it's you know it's a rule that should be
made by this superintendent and the
school board shouldn't be rules made by
us down here
you know it's a shame that you guys know
what site you play on
further discussion representative tanner
um well while i support
representative woodcock's local uh
local controlled
idea vaccinations are usually under the
purview of the um
the health and human services
and not under education so um
i think this bill is totally in the
wrong place
further discussion
yes represent cordelia uh thank you the
other bill that i was uh referring to
that does mandate vaccinations in order
to attend a public school is placed in
the public health uh section um of law
so uh i i think that this is um
uh needed for that reason
represent luno
thank you mr chair so um yes we actually
heard from abby rogers of the
department of health and human services
who specifically said that this bill is
not necessary since only uh
the commissioner of the department of
health and human services can authorize
a vaccine be required for um for schools
so and that's done through rsa 141 c
colon 20. so
so
this bill um is um is definitely not
needed
and
and um you know and should be uh you
know should be itl
further discussion
not cna reps and nelson are you ready
not really
12 41
yes and the motion is ought to pass
okay
all right here we go representative
cordelli
yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson
yes
yes representative
representative hopson
yes representative ford
yes representative soda yes
representative nelson nine yes
uh representative luno
no
representative cornell
no representative jake
no
tanner
no representative ellison
representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative porter
not here did i
miss somebody's name paul
oh okay
porter was no not here not here i'm
sorry
cross her out
representative hall no she's a lucky one
representative lad
yes that's 10 to 8.
the next uh
we'll have a minority report from uh
representative woodruff
representative woodcock
okay
1376.
to inclusion of charter public schools
since no we've done that one
um
we did 13 14 02 but i was looking at
13.76
did we do it
well i had it down okay
1332 accepting public universities and
colleges from requirement requirements
under print medical freedom in
immunizations
you know oh that's right that was the
one you're hearing
um
looking for a motion
i'll move um odd to pass
bill number again please
i didn't i did not recognize you though
yes so i'm going to recognize represent
hobson
i'll make a motion of ito
is there a second oh second
who was that
okay
represent lexus makes the second
represent hobson makes the
motion
of uh
itl
would you like to speak to your motion
i can at the second can speak first and
the first can speak second that'd be
fine
um one of the things they were talking
about in in this
was
well somebody could just bring in a
medical exemption
and the problem with that is
certain departments in the federal
government have passed down to the heads
of certain hospital associations that if
any of their doctors
issue a medical exemption they'll be
fired
so it makes it kind of hard to get a
medical exemption
and and i know that there was a nurse at
concord
whose doctor did want her to have a
medical exemption
couldn't give it to her
he knew she might be at risk but on the
other hand if she didn't get
the vaccine she would be fired from her
job
she got it and with it and they tell me
she was within 10 to 15 seconds of being
dead
because she went into anaphylactic shock
which is what the doctor was afraid of
so
threatening people with their jobs one
way or the other
is inexcusable and in this case you're
threatening somebody
with their chance of being able to even
get a k an education to get a job and
that is unacceptable thank you
representatives do you have
i i will just add that in our
constitution part first bill of rights
article four
right of conscience unalienable
thank you further discussion
representative uh woodcock
thank you everyone i just wanted to
respond
it was interesting to hear
representative leakers say threatening
people with their jobs is unconscionable
but you just did it two bills ago the
teachers i'm asking
quote of conduct
only if they disobey the law
representative
ellison did you have your hand up
representative tanner
uh thank you
certain jobs require certain
prerequisites
and
some of those prerequisites are
vaccinations so that you are not
um
at
a point where you're
spreading germs
bacteria
viruses
um on
people who are the most vulnerable and
that's been something that's um
in the medical field for a long time
in fact when i first started teaching
you had to take a tb test
and some places had chest x-rays and and
uh
had to get vaccinations um you know to
be an emt
so uh
this is something that um
really flies in the face of
you know the history of our nation the
history of jobs the things that have
worked
into
common practice
further disguise represent luna
thank you very much mr chair um you know
what's really exciting about um some of
the some of the improvements that have
been
uh that have come out during this
session is that we're live streamed on
youtube and that these videos are going
to be around for a while so i know it
was said a lot last session people are
watching but people really are watching
and i think they've got a great
opportunity particularly particularly
today to know who your representatives
are and how they vote on important
issues and so people are watching and
i'm really glad for that and i think
november is really going to show the
results of that thank you
represent hobson
thank you
mr chair and and thank you
representative luno for pointing that
out um i think it's very important to
know how your representatives vote on
important things that affect your your
medical uh privacy your your family and
medical decisions so i'm sure that my
constituents i mean i'm here
as a result of them putting me here so
that isn't why i wanted to speak
but i think that the other part that
we're not paying attention to is natural
immunity
they refute there has been no
validation for natural immunity
and
if
i'm not a scientist i don't know who
who on this board is a scientist
but there is
information that we don't have about
whether or not this is a vaccine or a
therapeutic and i will leave the medical
decisions to medical people and i would
like my family decisions to be my
decision
thank you representative cordelli uh
thank you and just to follow up on that
i believe that there are uh numerous
studies about uh natural immunity
and um many that even uh um have uh
um found a much greater uh prevention um
when there is natural immunity as
opposed to the vaccination
further just represent tanner
yes i'd just like to say that you know
we're concerned with the enrollment in
our colleges and universities
and
i think parents may think twice
about sending their kids to unh or
granite state college
if
they realize that a lot of people are
going there without the basic
vaccinations
i grew up in an age when
we had people in iron lungs because of
polio
and now it's eradicated in in the world
almost because of or smallpox i had
i had smallpox vaccination and then when
i went overseas when i was like 18 i had
to have another small tax vaccination
and smallpox is another
uh
very nasty disease that's been almost
totally eradicated in in the world and
it's because of vaccinations
thank you
further discussion representatives
i didn't want to get into this but you
brought small pox up smallpox was a true
vaccination
if you took the small fox vaccination
you did not get smallpox if you take
this vaccination you can still get
coven 19 in fact you can get it three
times
as
some people here we know
and so the point is
this vaccination
does not and was never designed to keep
you from getting coveted it was designed
to keep you from getting as sick it was
designed to keep you out of the hospital
and also and this is according to the
cdc by the way and according to the cdc
it does not keep you from spreading the
disease either which was why in the
beginning when they brought it out they
said please keep wearing masks because
this will not keep you
from
spreading the disease it will not keep
you from getting the disease that was
not the design the design was to keep
you out of the hospital and to keep you
from dying and so comparing those two
are two totally different things thank
you
mr chair
is this bill just about covert because i
reading the bill i thought it applied to
any vaccination
i think this one is uh
relative code
this is just cover that from what i got
i don't have them for me but as i recall
further discussion
not seeing any uh representing nelson
all right uh sure i'm on the right page
at this point uh 1332
and the motion is
ideal
okay representative
cordelli yes
representative notter yes representative
johnson
yes representatives yes
representative first team yes
representative hopson
yes representative ford yes
representative soda yes representative
nelson yes
representative luno
no
representative jack no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison not here
no
representative uh woodcock
representative hall
no
representative uh lat yes
okay attending
okay uh who's going to be writing the
minority
yeah i think this is the last one 1376.
1376 the bill relative to the
participation in education freedom
accounts from
program by students with disabilities
i have one here zero four three nine h
is that the one you're talking about
okay i'm looking at an older one then
okay
uh
is it zero eight four zero eight four
zero i got it
correct
okay let's see where we are here
okay represent hobson you're recognized
for
emotion you have that down
uh
i would like like to make a motion for
itl
sir a second
represent cordelli makes the second
representative hobson makes the motion
uh itl for hb
1376 represent hobson
well i i don't have a copy of that
amendment so i can only speak to albert
speak to bill you know okay
okay so you guys are getting a lot of
deb today
um
my motion is itl children in approved
non-public schools requiring special
education services are still covered by
idea and section us
i wrote section twice sorry usc section
1412a using an individual service plan
special education services that may have
been offered and delivered by public
school or sending districts or local
education agencies are held at the same
are held at the school for the child for
a period of time in the event the child
returns to their sending district the
child can pick up where they left off so
i believe the bill relative to
participation in education freedom
accounts by students with disabilities
there are
rules already in place
that explain
to parents
the application shall contain the
following
number one an explanation of allowable
uses of efa funds the responsibilities
of parents or guardians the duties of
the scholarship organization and the
role of any financial management firms
that the scholarship organization may
contract with to administer
any aspect of the efa program
and then number two it notices as
follows particip participation in the
efa program is a parental placement
under 20 usc section 1412.
i'll end it there thank you instead of
reading the whole statute
is there any further
okay is there any
further
representative cornell
if i could speak to my amendment which
what the wording of which was given to
me by becky fredet from the department
of education
thinking that this would help with the
students
attending a
parentally placed
who are parentally placed with
disabilities and all it does is ensure
that the scholarship organization shall
provide parents of students with
disabilities who are not enrolled in a
private elementary or secondary school
an explanation of their rights that such
students have under idea and any
applicable state laws
so all it does is ensure that parents
receive a copy of what their rights are
which i guess from
history they don't always
get a copy that's handed to them and
explained they're given a lot of
information as anybody who's ever seen
special ed laws and rules
knows so this is just to ensure that
they know that
that's all thank you
further discussion
on the bill represent luna thank you
very much yeah i i mean i think as as
representative cornell was saying this
um um this amendment was uh was really
developed collaboratively with um with
the department with um with attorney
zellin
and with um with others involved in um
uh in this area and it's been through
obviously the bill is introduced an
earlier draft of the amendment which
representative cordelli
took issue with the terms possess and
wave we agreed with that and uh and then
brought forth uh amendment 840 which um
which really just makes it clear that
that parentally what rights parentally
placed students have
not possess or waive but have under idea
in any applicable state laws it does it
in two different places here
and it and it makes it clear
that
that that parents of students with
disabilities
in the efa program would receive an
explanation of the rights that they have
under idea and applicable state laws
this makes a lot of sense
this is is i think an example of a bill
where where or particularly as of an
amendment where where we're trying to
work together to uh to to improve the
the information that uh that parents of
students with disabilities receive
and um and you know we've taken into
consideration
i think the feedback that we had during
earlier discussions on this bill with
the language and to to summarily
unilaterally reject it on party lines is
is just
it's it's no more shocking than a lot of
other bills we've seen but i think given
the um given the collaborative work
given the department's interest in the
language
and um and given that uh that that you
know it's it's um it's late and it's
been and it's been done and i think it's
it's ready to uh to go forward as not to
pass as amended to the house that that
we should um
maybe consider withdrawing the itl
motion and consider a new motion instead
represent like us
i i like all the wording in this and i
like the way you fixed it i'm still not
understanding why it's necessary since
it already says participation in the efa
program is a parental placement under 20
usc section 1412 and this is in the
this is in the application
so you can't possibly be in the program
without getting this notification
because you have to fill out the
application so when you go to fill out
the application it specifically says
participation in the eff program is a
parental placement under 20 usc section
1412 individuals with disabilities well
ida if a child with a disability is
enrolled in a non-public school a child
with a disability participating in an
efa program and enrolled in a public
school
under and it gives the rsa is not a
parental placement under ida and shall
be entitled to to fape
parentally placed private school
children with a disability shall not be
entitled to a faith in connection with
their enrollment by their parents in a
private school according with and again
it gives that and pursuant to
another piece of law while participating
in the state-funded efa program the
school district in which the child with
a disability participating in the efa
program enrolled in a public school
under again the rsa resides is
responsible for the provision of faith
so
i'm not sure that
what's in here is not in there and how
you cannot read it if it's part of the
application so i am i mean i'm willing
to listen but i'm not sure
what what it is
that
isn't that you need in addition to
what's already being done
further
uh comments or just yes representative
so representative lacus i'm in the
application
and i can't get to any of that unless i
create a login
and
all i did was go to the
the department of ed go to the efa
accounts go to the application part and
click on new
families i think it's called new
families um
and i can't get there i can't i can't
get in into that so
when you talk about you know how come we
haven't seen it how come we haven't read
it it's because i can't get in no i
didn't ask that i mean i you know
i
well it's in rules but it also
um
you have to click on the part if you if
you're a family
and you say yes you have qual a
qualified disability
in the app then you get that language
okay so
but i would have to i'd have to have a
i'd have to have a log in and get in
that far to the process
to be able to see it well you have to
say yes i have a disability yeah and
that immediately the app immediately
brings up a different section
and you would read it there and then you
have to click something you have to
actually click something that says i
have read this requirement
okay so
that's what i'm saying it's you can't
possibly
no i i hear what you're saying and i
guess if um if i were at the point where
i was ready to commit to an efa and
actually fill out the application that
that would be easy enough
um i think representative cornell's bill
uh was meant to or the amendment was
meant to
sort of have
easy access early on that uh
you know you didn't have to go looking
for and
so i you know i think that's something
that's worthy of consideration whether
or not it
should be something that the scholarship
organization actually sends out or gives
to a family rather than having the
family find it on its own actually she
to continue on you could have gotten
there all you needed to scroll and click
yes to qualify you didn't have to be
logged in you had didn't have to
anything so when you're just curious
like you just were
you could have gotten to that just by
clicking yes that you had a disability
and if you want to do that
are there any is there furthest
discussion from anybody here
not seeing any
uh
would you please call the role we are
voting on the amendment oh wait no no no
no no no oh the idea okay
with no no amendment correct right okay
representative cordelli
yes
representative
nutter otter yes representative johnson
yes representative lucas yes
representative bursting yes
representative hopson
yes representative
ford
yes
representative soda yes representative
nelson yes
representative luna absolutely not
representative
jack no
representative cornell no representative
tanner
absolutely not
representative ellison
no
representative mullen no
representative woodcock
representative hall
no
and representative ladd yes
okay
who's who's doing the uh
um
that takes us down through all the bills
i think we had assigned to our committee
um
that's 103 of them
somebody tell me what they did with the
because i just heard you mention the uh
the amendment 0840 what did we ever do
with that
we didn't do anything with it
just discussed
okay
yeah that would be a minority amendment
uh that they'd want for your their ought
to pass right
yeah
okay so as a reminder to everybody we
need to get the reports done
get them to me as quick i know you're
exhausted we're all exhausted tired
but we need to get them done for for
getting to lindsey
thank you
yeah
mr chairman never call me again to be
clerk
i gotcha
thank you
you